good morning everyone welcome to Ways
and Means today we'll be looking at
agency presentations and we'll start
with the Department of Justice is Warren
here excellent come on up
testing great okay
good to know thanks
good morning my name is Warren cormack
I'm an attorney at the Department of
Justice I manage the tobacco Master
settlement agreement
and I ensure diligent enforcement of RSA
541 C and 541d the statutes that govern
uh diligent enforcement of the
Ambassador settlement agreement
I submitted a memorandum on February 2nd
2023 detailing the estimated payments
for 2023 through 2025
from the master settlement agreement
and in that memorandum I outlined some
factors that change the payments
payments are very difficult to predict
and any estimate is likely to be wrong
past actual payments have varied widely
from estimated payments
that said the current estimated payment
for 2023 is around 42 million dollars
some of the factors that go towards MSA
payments include the volume of
cigarettes sold across the United States
inflation whether a tobacco company
decides to dispute a portion of the
payment
whether a state has diligently enforced
the tobacco statutes and other factors
go towards the some that we eventually
perceive
and many of those factors vary up until
the point of distribution
I'd be happy to answer any questions
about
the tobacco Master settlement agreement
estimated payments or anything like that
thank you that was concise of course the
big question is well how much do they
fluctuate uh what What's the variance
last year the variance from the
originally estimated amount was around
10 million dollars and in past years
it's not unheard of for
it to be around five million dollars
thank you other questions yes
representative Ames
good morning
um
do you was there anything special that
happened last time around that boosted
the revenues is 48 a particularly High
number I don't have the you know over a
series of years yes 48 is a very high
number and there are a couple factors
that go towards that the first
the first is uh inflation
um inflation was very high in 2021 it
was higher than we have ever seen it uh
before in the course of receiving
payments which started in 1999 that was
when we first started tracking inflation
it uh I recall correctly it didn't raise
above four or five percent uh up until
this past year
and so that's a big factor uh we also
there were fewer disputes to the payment
than we
uh conservatively estimated there might
be so that was another factor that went
towards a payment that was higher than
anticipated
representative ulrey has a question
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question uh a comment first we
hear better if that microphone is closer
thank you
uh this we have speakers from each one
of us I see
um
when you talk about 48 million that's a
dollar value do you have access to or
information about the number of cartons
sold because that's that would give a
better fact uh figure to us regarding uh
an increase or decrease in uh
individual sales uh the amount of
Revenue that is received we can then
adjust by taxation purposes but if we
know whether this is a a decreasing line
or an increasing line regarding the
number of packages or cartons in this
case sold would
I think give us a a sense as to
what uh revenues may or may not be uh
expected uh there are a couple ways that
I should answer that question the first
is that tobacco sales generally Decline
and one of the factors that I failed to
mention into the previous question is
that 19 really affected cigarette sales
they skyrocketed and so that contributed
to the higher payment and now that
things are evening out it could be that
we continue to see declines and that is
what the future payments account for
with respect to how cigarette sales
track the MSA payment
the short answer is They Don't Really uh
they they do in the sense that the MSA
payment tracks
on the first instance a base amount that
New Hampshire receives that is then
increased by the volume of cigarettes
but then the subsequent modifications to
that number
can cause it to vary widely to the point
that
the eventual payment doesn't track
actual sticks sold to a degree that
would be uh particularly useful which is
why one of the reasons why I report in
the potential estimated amount
the way that the MSA payment works is
not like uh the way that the department
Revenue collects tobacco taxes the MSA
payment is based in a contract between
the states and the tobacco companies and
the tobacco companies can for example
dispute a portion of their payment under
that contract and there's not a lot that
the states can do to
get that money if it's disputed and sent
into a separate account and not sent to
the states
I'll follow up
yeah that yes that is a contract but
that contract is based in large part on
um
well the MSA is not but the the the uh
volume of sales by a particular
manufacturer who's a
has an input and that is the basis for
them to dispute sections based upon
their volume of sales and whether or not
they're actually selling this much or
that much and therefore they owe this
much of that much
am I not correct on that
uh you you are correct in the first
instance that the base payment is first
adjusted for volume
then it's adjusted for uh profit so
there's an adjustment that's based in
profit there are adjustments on which
companies need to pay how much
proportionally based on which ones were
original signatories to the agreement
which ones were subsequent signatories
to the agreement there's also a very
significant inflation adjustment that
on the lowest amount increases it by
three percent every year last year it
was over seven percent so
and then their subsequent adjustments
for
different categories of States uh and
then a significant adjustment for
the npm adjustment which is called the
npm because it stands for
non-participating manufacturers so these
are tobacco companies that actually are
not on the MSA that
sell cigarettes in the state and uh
one of the things that I do is enforce
the tobacco statutes and when we enforce
the tobacco statutes for those
npms which levels the playing field
across
the tobacco companies that are obligated
to pay to the states
it makes the other tobacco companies
that are not signatories to the
agreement pay into an escrow fund to
level out the amount that they're taking
out of
what they sell and so if we diligently
enforce those statutes then
we receive a certain amount as a result
of that but that could also reduce and
then it also doesn't there's also the
factor of bankruptcy so it is there are
a lot of factors that go into the
equation that aren't volume granted
volume is a major factor in the amount
that we receive
uh
it's
I guess what I'm trying to say is that
there's a reason as to why this is
reported as a dollar figure as opposed
to
a stick figure
representative Army and then we'll work
our way around the room and then we'll
go back around if we need to
I believe
five years where there was a log Jam of
disputes on between the tobacco
companies and the states about whether
the states were doing proper enforcement
or not can you tell whether that's been
resolved enough that we're not going to
see that affecting things anymore
uh I would love to be able to say that
we are not going to see that affect
things but the reality of the how the
payments work is that in any year
tobacco companies have the ability to
dispute the payment that we might
receive and so
it's very hard to account for that in
any sort of payment estimate
because it could happen at the moment of
just distribution and we suddenly
realize that there's a large portion
that's disputed and Those portions can
be
several hundreds of Millions for the
total States receiving which can
translate to a significant portion for
New Hampshire
as far as the past
disputed payments
I don't have an answer for you right now
as to how much I believe you're talking
about a portion of payments that were
withheld from roughly like 2005 to
2011-ish
I don't have an answer for you as to how
much of that the states have received or
not but
you're correct in so far as any time a
portion of the payment is disputed
oftentimes it gets sent into a separate
a disputed payments account and then it
could potentially be paid out to the
state so
that's another factor that makes it
difficult to predict because we could
have an upward
adjustment as a result of that quick
follow-up
thank you so you can't tell whether they
dumped a lot of money on us last year
from one of those holding accounts last
year
basically there were there were two
major factors the first is inflation
which was
um
higher than we've ever seen before uh as
it relates to the MSA payment it was
over seven percent
uh and then the other Factor was covid
which caused profits to increase it
caused a a lot of uh cigarettes to be
sold and it caused more expensive
cigarettes to be sold like more premium
Brands which tend to be party to the MSA
as opposed to more discount Brands which
tend not to be speaking generally
and so
those two factors combined with the fact
that the companies didn't dispute as
much as they
might have
led to a much higher payment than usual
representative Platt has a question
yes thank you for taking my question you
mentioned that the forecast you give
could be two million to five million off
either way or is there a bias
it could be more than that off I don't I
don't want to give the impression that I
um I'm limiting the degree to which this
could be off if every Tobacco Company
went bankrupt today uh then you know it
could just go away for the next you know
so it's it's a really difficult thing to
predict
um
that said uh I'm I might have
interrupted you I want to make sure that
I'm directly answering your question the
question was is that two to five or
whatever the number is was the Fair
statement is that biased up or but down
or is it either side are your estimates
come out in the middle or is there a
bias uh high or bias low that's our math
here
the estimates
we try to be somewhat conservative that
said again there are a lot of factors
that go into this and
um
I wouldn't count on the estimated
payments being under uh particularly in
light of possible disputes
inflation possibly going down I mean
it's very difficult to say
whether it's going to be higher or lower
than the actual payment
any other questions on this side
back over here then representative Ames
I should know the answer to this but
does the MSA agreement run out at some
point in time is there an end date to
this thing if my understanding of the
MSA is if they the signatories to the
agreement are selling cigarettes we're
receiving money from the sale of those
cigarettes
so okay we're gonna put you on the spot
here what if you could give a percentage
to your percentage of certainty with the
numbers you gave us is it 80 is it more
it just so we have a rough idea oh it
the numbers are wrong uh but I would say
zero percent
um
yeah as far as the general trend
the general trend has generally been
downwards but that was completely
reversed in covet 19.
um all right so we're going to throw a
dart and do the best we can we
appreciate you thank you so much thank
you okay we will now invite up well go
ahead I'm sorry we have a question I'm
sorry could you stay for one more
question
thank you madam chair
uh thank you for taking my question so
the numbers are wrong are they high or
low wrong
take a wild guess so I I tried I tried
to answer that question
um as it related to whether the
estimates were conservative or not
um
the it is very difficult to predict uh
and the estimates don't account as I
said for bankruptcy they don't account
for possible Menthol bans which have
been going into in some jurisdictions
which actually can affect uh New
Hampshire because MSA payments are
sent to the entirety of the U.S and then
distributed based on allocation
percentages to the states so what
happens in a different state actually
does affect us to some degree so uh it's
very difficult to predict okay follow-up
question please follow up so could you
uh please provide us with a chart of
some kind bar chart any kind of graph so
we can just see what the numbers look
like
pictorially would you do that for us
please
I I can do that
um
uh the National Association for
Attorneys General publishes a chart like
that it's worth keeping in mind that New
Hampshire is a signatory to more than
just the MSA we're also a signatory to
What's called the npm ASA which is the
non-participating manufacturer
oh
thank you for the reminder
so New Hampshire is a signatory to the
MSA but also subsequent agreements that
increase the amount we're paid in
addition to the MSA payment so a lot of
the charts that are are published on
this don't necessarily address the other
agreements that were
party to like for example the npma essay
okay so is that something you can break
out for New Hampshire or not I I could
look at
past Trends I don't have that
information immediately on hand
okay very good thank you madam chair
thank you those are good questions and
and we'll see if you could work with
maybe Chris Shea on uh getting a little
bit more information on this so we just
know what we're looking for
so just for clarification when you ask
for a chart are you just asking for
what's been provided over let's say the
last 10 years or 15 years yeah I was
thinking like five to ten years before
covid so we could see where it was going
and then the impact to covet because it
doesn't surprise me to hear that it's
spiked I mean I think alcohol sales were
up too
so so we can do that but that is also
contained in the Akbar you have a
10-year picture of the revenue that we
received through tobacco settlement but
I can pull that together because it's in
the general fund in the education trust
fund so
um the other thing just to keep in mind
too is that with the settlement funds
the first 40 million dollars that comes
to the state goes directly into the
education trust fund any amount over 40
million would go into the general fund
so it's already been restricted to the
education trust fund per statute
representative question
what was the last time that we went
above 40.
yeah well it was above 40 last year but
we've spent above 40 for the last few
years
for covet and before that
so it's um
it's been above 40 all the way back to
2013.
oh I was remembering it may not be a lot
above 40. so in 2016 it was a million
four
but that went to the general fund so
we've got 41 million 400. back in 2013
we got 63 million but I think uh Mr
McCormick McCormick explained that
there's been some changes
um you know there's just different
factors that go into this and up through
2011-12 there was some significant
changes that were reconciled or
rectified that do impact the payments
okay
so I'm glad you're seeing how hard our
job is now because we have to put this
all together any other questions yes uh
representative thank you so would it be
fair to say that based on the past there
really is not likely to be a lot that's
going to go into the general fund
uh that's correct yeah yeah I mean I
think for our purposes that's kind of
the key that no there's not going to be
a lot probably going into the general
fund if there is great but probably not
thank you
the and I think just to add to I mean
this group in the past has relied on the
conservative estimates
um of the doj when they come in to give
you kind of the base number and you've
you've often just accepted that knowing
that there's a lot of factors that
influence what's going to come out in
the wash at the end
um and the numbers have been showing a
decline in the presentations over the
last couple of budget Cycles again I
think as Warren suggested that they're
considering the sales
um the you know the sale of tobacco or
cigarettes and and then other influences
on that if you see the trend down until
covet and then it popped up but I think
we're going to see it Trend down again
and I think when dra comes up you'll
hear a little bit about that in terms of
the tobacco sales in the state
thank you very much
okay so uh we have on our agenda the dra
at 10 30 but because this isn't an
actual public hearing on a bill and
they're here would you want to start
sooner okay great come on up
thank you
ready when you are welcome all right
good morning Madam chair members of the
committee Lindsey staff commissioner New
Hampshire Department of Revenue
Administration with me Keene Wong tax
policy Council you've probably seen
Keane quite a bit so far this session
um what we're going to do today is kind
of a follow-up presentation to the Joint
economic briefing that we did a few
weeks ago
some things in this presentation will
seem a little bit repetitive but I
assume many of you are kind of feeling
like you're drinking from a fire hose at
the moment with the amount of
information that we're you're receiving
so we're going to go through everything
one more time my goal to with this
presentation is it to serve as a
reference for you
um as we go through the taxes and as we
go through the revenue estimating
process most of the information that
you'll need will be contained within
this presentation so
um if anybody needs some light bedtime
reading you may refer to it from time to
time over the next couple months
um I will note the date on the front
page is the date of our original
presentation I decided to save paper and
ink and I left that date but feel free
to cross it out and update it with
February 7th of 2023.
just as a reminder the mission of the
Department of Revenue is to fairly and
efficiently administer the tax laws of
the State of New Hampshire collecting
the proper amount of taxes due incurring
the least cost to taxpayers in amer in a
manner that merits the highest degree of
public confidence in our integrity
further we provide prompt and
constructive assistance to the municipal
units of government in matters of Budget
Finance and the appraisal of Real Estate
on slide three taxpayer interaction it's
a policy of the dra to administer the
tax laws of the state in a manner that
demonstrates efficiency fairness and
courtesy to every taxpayer
slide four just a general overview of
the organizational structure of the dra
we have four divisions the audit
division which does exactly that they
audit taxpayers Returns the collections
division they collect past due amounts
for the Department the municipal and
property division sets the tax rates for
the municipalities across the state
provides support to the municipal units
of government and assist with the
appraisal of real estate and then all
the way on the right the taxpayer
services division this is our division
that processes the payments that we
receive the tax returns that we receive
they are the ones that answer the phones
in our call center and they perform kind
of routine account maintenance so
they're kind of a One-Stop shop for
taxpayers so long as you are not under
audit and we are not trying to collect
from you most of your interactions will
be with our taxpayer services division
all the way on the left you'll see the
administration unit this is the back
office functions of the department
um including legal hearings internal
audit Human Resources business office
Etc
I'm going to turn it over to Keen
through to walk through the next few
slides thank you
good morning
um so
okay so the uh this on the slide five uh
some brief information on the tax policy
and legislative analysis group and this
is one of the uh the groups that's in
the in the business uh administrative
unit that was mentioned in the previous
slide
within this group there are the three of
us that's me uh tax policy Council and
there's uh Lauren Sullivan she's the
senior financial analyst and that's
Wendy metivier she's a financial analyst
and you probably have seen emails from
Wendy on a monthly basis with the
reports that that we we generate
um and the function of this group is
essentially
um to assist in the in legislative work
with the committee and with legislators
so we prepare fiscal note worksheets and
quick guides for legislation so that
that's about right now when um lsrs or
bills are introduced in uh fiscal notes
requests are made so we had a team that
work on the fiscal worksheets and we
prepare the quick guides as you as you
have seen during the committee hearings
I pass out the quick guides to uh to
members of the committee
um and then we also would work with
legislators in analyzing the tax policy
and fiscal impact uh so to understand
the uh the fiscal worksheet that we
prepared and to talk talk to that
um and also we would attend hearings
um during for the House and Senate
committee and um the House and Senate
committee deliberation on the
legislation
and also at the same time we'll be
testifying before the House and Senate
committees on the uh on the tax policy
and fiscal impact uh uh and then on the
back end we also track legislations make
sure that we know what's going on and we
would also assist in Department rule
changes and form changes as uh generated
from the the new tax law changes
moving on to the next slide this is a a
great overview on the uh the Texas
administered by the dra so in fiscal
year 22 we administer about 2.9 billion
dollars in revenue of the uh of all the
taxes and on the left hand column you
see the tax type it's not in any means
uh organized by um alphabetical order so
um but it's the the two top headers for
business for tax tax revenue would be
the business Enterprise tax and business
profits tax
um and those two combine uh the the
business taxes for the state
um followed by then there's the CST the
IND and so on so forth so this is a list
of text types that that this
administered by the dra and on the
center column that's the uh the tax
rates the current tax rates and then on
the right hand column uh that's where if
you want to look at um do more research
on those text types the statutes are
listed on the on the third Column Way on
the right
yep
yeah go ahead and put your hand up sorry
I missed that go ahead and represent
fellows
um
so when you the middle column where it
says current tasks rate you're talking
about fy23
uh yes so that current tax rate is the
the current rate that's right now so
it's for uh tax year
um tax year 2022 I'll tax you 23.
in in oh yeah follow-up and are there's
there I know there are some scheduled to
be changed for next biennium yeah so I
know the business
I know which uh business profits I know
for sure is changing but can you no none
of them are actually changing unless we
pass legislation to do so this year
right so every all these rates are baked
baked in for tax year
yeah go ahead did you have something to
say representative Army did you want to
clarify something
oh yes but but not in tax year 2023.
you understand the difference between
tax year and fiscal year
I do okay
because we can go over that more if
you'd like
I I thought the business tax what what
was passed with the business tax uh
business I can't remember profits tax do
you want to go ahead and answer that
King yes so uh the tax rate is uh is
fixed by Statute the business tax is
what's going to change is the threshold
so on a bi-annual basis that threshold
is going to be adjusted based on CPI
consumer price index of two years going
forward in entries so that's the BPT as
well as the bet
representative fellas I believe the rate
change that you're referring to was the
BPT rate going from 7.6 percent to 7.5
we're showing 7.5 on this chart and that
7.5 percent rate is for taxable periods
ending on or after 12 31 of 2023.
so because we are in 2023 calendar year
2023 at the moment we included that
seven percent rate so it's it has this
chart has already accounted for the rate
change that you are thinking of I
believe
go ahead so I'm just trying to learn
here so if that's tax year
2023 isn't that Revenue coming in in 20
in fiscal year
four
so we will start receiving estimated
payments for tax year ending 1231 23
starting in April which would be fiscal
year 23. we'll receive another set of
estimate payments in June which will be
fiscal year 23 but returns won't be
filed until fiscal 24. we have a nice
chart that we can maybe share with you
about how the tax years kind of straddle
the fiscal years because it it can be
confusing and so we try to be very clear
when we're talking tax year versus
fiscal year because they're not
necessarily the same
okay
yes there is a chart coming up
representative that would be uh exactly
answered to your issue
and so moving on to slide seven
and this is a breakup of the uh the
revenue uh by text type and you see here
that the uh as I mentioned earlier the
the big Revenue maker here would be
business taxes and you see that's 1.2 uh
well
1.2 billion of the total 2.9 billion of
uh revenue for fiscal year 22. and
that's about 40 of the of the total of
2.9 billion and um the next sort of
highest item
um that is on on the uh in terms of uh
amount would be the Statewide education
property tax and that's 13 of the 2.9
billion that's 363 and that's a fixed
amount by Statute
um
right
moving on to the next slide so here is a
pie chart a good pictorial uh showing
the um
the share of the the taxes in terms of
the tax type and you see here the once
again the the largest amount here is uh
business taxes which is made up of the
business profits tax which is 27 percent
and then combined with the business
Enterprise tax that's ten percent of all
the of all the total taxes now this is
the uh of the revenues this is the share
of unrestricted revenues my apologies
foreign
moving on to the next slide so that this
is uh going in right into the uh each
text type so first the text type that
we're talking about right now will be
the business profits tax
um as mentioned earlier just now um the
current rate is 7.5 percent of uh
taxable business profits and this is for
taxpayers ending on or after December 31
23. prior to that was a tax rate of um
7.6 percent and that was for tax peers
ending on or after December 3122 and
before that was 7.7 so that's just the
trend of the uh the PPT rates that's
going
um and so the tax is
is incurred on every Enterprise
organized for gain or profits carrying
on a business activity within the state
and then the third bullet point here is
the threshold which is the gross
business income in excess of hundred and
three thousand dollars for all
activities and this is adjusted uh for
for a CPI so every two years and this
will taxable peers beginning 1 123 so
the next one will be on uh one one uh
25.
um another point that uh that's not on
this slide is that uh just to mention
that we are conforming to the Internal
Revenue code uh as of December 31 2018
the New Hampshire business profits tax
is on a static Conformity so when uh
when you hear that oh
sorry uh so the New Hampshire business
profits taxes on a static Conformity
with the IRC uh so when you hear that
all the feds are making changes to the
uh to the tax laws that that does not
necessarily impact New Hampshire because
we are static to the December 31 2018.
uh in terms of filing of the BPT
the filing deadline is dependent on the
entity type so Partnerships returns are
due on March 15 whereas the corporate
Partnerships and fiduciary returns are
due April 15th and there's a seven month
extension that's available so if uh if
the entities find that they need more
time to file their returns they will
file an extension uh upon their due date
of the return
and during any particular tax year the
business entity the business
organization would be required to pay
estimated taxes if they think that their
liability exists 200 and the estimated
taxes is broken down to four payments
um it's the April 15th June 15 September
15 and December 15th this is based on a
calendar year filer so if it's not a
calendar filer you'll look at just the
fourth month the sixth month the ninth
month and the 12th month of the um of
the tax tax year
for New Hampshire vpt most 91 of our
filers are calendar year file is so you
see at those times you'll see the spike
in in Revenue
actually I have a quick question on
something and then we'll go to
representative Almy so uh you mentioned
that we are in static conformance with
IRC 2018 yes
but maybe one exception is well there
could be several but on the nol carry
forward I believe we're different from
that in terms of we have a Max on the
terms of number of years and the dollar
amount so those are not in conformance
at the moment that that is correct okay
so we are generally in Conformity to
2018 and then with other adjustments
specific to New Hampshire yes that's a
correct observation great thank you
representative
thank you hon if I'm a startup business
and I
on my liabilities is around 400 dollars
the year before
and I
um all of a sudden burst out and I'm
by
June
15 on I've got four times that amount
coming in
do you go back at the end of the year
and say hey you didn't pay the estimates
conforming to your activity
yes I believe we do uh the we will look
back to
um throughout the year
um and then if the taxpayer feels that
during at the earlier part of the year
that they received a large amount of
Revenue as at that time that they would
need to make the payment
um on increase the estimated payment uh
to to us to the dra yes that would
impact when
um in terms of underpayment penalty
calculations and things like that yes
however if the taxpayer pays in
estimated payments ninety percent of
their tax liability from the prior year
they would not be subject to the
underpayment Penalty so in your example
if they had a 200 liability in the prior
year and they made
um four fifty dollar payments equaling
that two hundred dollars but in the
current year suddenly their liability
was a thousand dollars they would not
receive an underpayment penalty because
they had essentially paid their prior
year amount
if that makes sense
questions over here representative Ames
I just wanted to point out and you can
correct me or spell this out a little
more than I can
that the timelines for filing returns
changed as I recall for partnership
returns and and corporate returns
um
so that when somebody like me is trying
to go back in time and compare
the month of April or March with prior
marches in aprils
we're comparing apples and oranges
because the partnership returns were due
here and there that kind of thing you're
correct so we changed the New Hampshire
changed the return due dates to conform
to the federal due dates so that you're
filing your New Hampshire return at the
same time that you're filing your
federal return so you will often hear us
say
it's best to really just combine March
and April revenues together and do that
if you're going to compare to Prior
Years
also I would just take this opportunity
to note the seven month extension that
Keane referenced it's a seven month
extension to file the return to actually
fill out the information and submit it
to the department it is not an extension
to pay so we you taxpayers should be
paying their full amount due in March
and April so we should be receiving the
revenue in March and April if they're a
calendar year filer but we give them a
seven month extension to fill out the
actual return with the information so
extension of time to file not extension
of time to pay
right okay
um so moving on to the next slide uh the
slide 10 and this is the slide that will
show
um the events of um the the text forms
that we're receiving as compared to the
calendar year and also of course
layering it on to a fiscal year on the
top part of it uh the first bar the
first calendar you see January to
December that's a calendar year 2022 and
then on the bottom it's a fiscal year 23
which is July 22 through June 23. so
going back to the calendar year
pictorial you'll see that in March which
is the uh the due date for the
partnership returns this is 2021
partnership returns filed in March of 22
and then you then April would be the uh
um the corporate returns and then that's
also when you will see the first
estimate for 20 calendar year 2022
payments
so you see April there'll be two events
happening which is the filing of returns
for corporate followers as well as
estimated payments and it may would be
the non-profit filers and in June will
be the second estimate payments for
2022.
so all that but you see that from
January to June 2022 that all that
actually falls into fiscal year of 22
and then fiscal year 23 starts in July
of 22 onwards and you'll see the the
first event that happens is the uh the
third payment of the estimates in
September 22 and then you'll have the um
the October Returns on extensions for
Partnerships because it's seven month
extension from March so the Thousand
October and in November uh is the
settlement extension for corporate
filers so filing in November 22. and
then in December uh you the uh
the big thing here it would be the the
fourth quarter estimate for uh 22
estimate payments
and so that's layered on to if you've
layered that onto the fiscal year 22
calendar and you'll see how all that
plays into uh in terms of when things
are happening that was very helpful I
think to see visually like that
representative fellows has a question
yes in in terms of
the the
looking at the revenues that come in for
this tax
can you tell me any kind of split in
terms of what kind of calendar years the
filers are using are most of them are
most of them using a calendar year or
something else yes about 91 percent of
our filers on calendar year filers
all right
representative Almy has a question
uh yes I was under the impression that
the the filers in October
air time were
were sending quite a lot more money than
than the ones that had a regular
calendar year
oh uh using fiscal year filers uh
sending in more money than um Calia
filers
as a whole
um
it
potentially we'll have to look into that
um but usually if
so in terms of trying to uh tolerate
tolerate correlate uh Revenue amounts
with filers I would say that
um
most of our big Revenue filers are what
is h filers and if and so there are
corporate returns and if they are on a
fiscal year basis then you'll see that
the that the payments would
blend in with their fiscal year period
tax tax period
um so yeah oh sorry
yeah
follow-up I I believe that's what was
causing what I thought was a lot more
money coming in on the the fiscal year
filers
um
if I could just ask one more while I'm
at it sure on I have never seen the
return due for non-profits what are they
returning
it would be for any
um business income that's unrelated to
their non-profit Mission so if they
um happen to be a non-profit that owned
rental property and they received money
related to that rental property and that
rental property is unrelated to their
charitable Mission then um that they
would file a BPT return we don't receive
a lot of them but it is technically in
statute so we want it to be thorough
yeah
Council
right so moving on to the next slide is
a slide 11. this is a historical
business tax returns estimates
extensions tax notice payments and
refunds
um so this chart here shows the movement
of the revenue and it's a year-over-year
change basis so you see the percentage
numbers on the bar charts itself those
are percentage of changes from one year
to the next year
okay
um and in fiscal year 22
um the total amount of uh Revenue here
is a 1.2 billion and then uh for fiscal
year 21 is one slightly over 1 billion
um the the amount for fiscal year 23
that is only through December of 23
currently
so it's only half
of it also it's good just a good
takeaway from this this chart here you
will see that the majority of the
payments here are essentially estimate
payments
yes representative ulry
word thank you
this is a little academic exercise if
you will
could we get
a chart
or a graphic display of some kind
that compares where we are now
with other years
just gross it doesn't need to be broken
down into everything just the gross
revenues so that we could compare
what percentage
that we've received now
for example last year which was the
banner year
are we ahead of behind about right
and then if you could go back to 14 it
would be that because you just have it
around 14 that's on here
am I making my
it gives us
I'm thinking that is wouldn't this chart
actually answer your question though
this chart tells us how much was
received but how much was received at
this time of year it does not say
oh
can I ask you to hold your question
until slide 55
and then we can
because I think we have part of what you
need there but I think we need to add to
it
fair enough okay representative
Schamberg has a question
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
looking at this chart here fiscal year
2023 which we're halfway through and
if there was to be a change in what is
coming in are there any alarm bells that
go off or anything in your organization
that says uh oh
we
have a problem coming up
I thank you for that question because
you're going to allow me to say one of
my favorite little tax Jokes which many
of you have heard before but bear with
me for a minute so
um as Keane mentioned the majority of
Revenue that we receive is in the form
of estimated payments
an estimated payment is a very simple
form with the taxpayer's name
identification number and a dollar
amount
um my joke is there's never uh or very
rarely are there little love notes that
tell me why that estimate payment may be
different from prior estimated payments
for that business or maybe different
from prior Year's estimated payments if
taxpayers would like to include that I
would love it because it would give us
better insight to your point so we
really just track how the estimated
payments have kind of performed to Prior
quarters and prior years and we can kind
of see if there are Trends happening to
date we are not seeing any alarm Bells
estimates are still strong in December
for business taxes so
it's a bit of a challenge where the
majority of our revenue is coming in
with very little information that
information is coming in when that
return is filed and that can be you know
if our calendar year filer where their
year ends at the end of December we may
not receive that return till the
following November so I've got almost 10
to 11 months where I'm waiting for that
information to know what's really going
on so it is a struggle with the majority
of the revenue coming in with with
estimates
foreign
moving on to the next slide so being
said that the estimates make a large
majority of the other Revenue so we did
analysis on the estimate itself and
breaking that down to the various uh
entity types and once again the takeaway
here has been the theme of this uh
presentation on BPT so far is that the
majority of the payments are coming from
corporate filers
moving on to the next slide slide 13 and
this is a chart that shows try to break
up the um to show the the types of
filers and the um the amount of the
percentage of the BPT that those filers
are paying into this is essentially a um
an extract that's from our pyramids
um reverse pyramid chart that's in our
annual report and here you'll see on the
left hand side these are the uh entity
type filers
um the the largest amount of filers here
are proprietorships makes up 39.6
percent however the percent of the
revenue BPT Revenue that's brought in by
this proprietorship is only 4.3 percent
of the BPT tax
and then you move down on the left hand
side you see that a Water's Edge filers
5.8 percent of filers at Water's Edge
but then they make up 57.6 of the BPT
Revenue
and moving on to the next slide slide 14
here is the uh the reverse triangle
um and this is uh taken straight from
our annual report
um and you'll see that the the bottom
part of the triangle is the uh the
larger amount of tax being reported
and the count here is 78
um 78 followers with the larger than 1
million
um and you see here the BPT sum is 200
200 million dollars
um and the population is only 0.1
percent
making more sense of discharge you move
down to the second part of the chart you
hear you see corporations and Waters
Edge the count of filers is about 30 30
000 filers and the sum of BPT is about
400 million dollars and um compared to
the total of 500 million dollars
foreign
moving on to the next slide slide 15
here is a trend analysis A tenure Trend
analysis of the BPT Revenue uh the Blue
Line being the uh BPT audited revenue
and the green dash line is the fiscal
year 23 plan revenue and you see there
is a slight dip in fiscal year 20 going
from fiscal year 19 of 473 million to
450 million and that is likely a small
covet adjustment there and then but
after that as we all not see in the news
and see what's happening with revenues
businesses and uh just somehow doing
really well and right now we are above
plan
foreign
so that concludes the BPT presentation
uh we're going to move on to bet
right okay
um so business Enterprise tags it's uh
it's it's in tandem with the business
profits tags so it's um to make up the
total business taxes it's Point
currently is 0.55 of the Enterprise
Value tax base uh and that's for
taxpayers ending December 31 22. the
Enterprise Value tax base is make is
made up of the dividends paid the
compensation and wages accrued and paid
and the interest paid or recruit
um every Prof every profit and
non-profit Enterprise or organization
with the business activity inside New
Hampshire other than the 501c3 will be
subject to the subject to the bet the
threshold for bet is slightly higher and
it is a 281 thousand dollars for both
Enterprise Value tax base as well as
close receipts
um and that
threshold is for taxpayers beginning 1 1
of 23 and it's also going to be adjusted
on a bi-annual basis based on uh CPI
uh interesting to note is that the BET
taxes
um that is paid will be considered as a
credit against BPT so essentially
um the whatever bad taxes that tax
liability that you have is going to be
uh used to reduce the BPT soil overall
uh where if you have your BPT higher
than your bad overall what that means is
that you're just paying essentially the
BPT tax because whatever
is credited against PPT
uh if in the situation where you have
excess bet
um that will be able to be carried over
for 10 years
the filing for the BET return is uh
similar to the BBT return so
Partnerships returns are due March 15th
corporate files are April 15 and so on
so forth with the same seven month
extensions as well as with the um the
estimate payments so there's no need for
filing uh splitting your filing
requirements between bad and BPT so you
just file one all at the same time
but do you have a slide that goes over
what's included in that Enterprise Value
you know payroll interest expense yeah
right could you explain that so
um so the Enterprise Value tax base is
made up of the dividends paid uh the
comp and wages paid recruit and interest
paid or accrued uh you we sort of we see
that a majority of the um
the bulk of the uh
the component that makes up the
Enterprise Value tax base is the the
Company wages
so payroll yes payroll gotcha questions
yes representative fellows
so you mentioned benefits doesn't
doesn't that include like medical
insurance
no can you repeat the question I'm sorry
the
follow-up to the um chairperson's
question the business the base for the
business Enterprise tax you mentioned at
first that it covered wages and benefits
so what about things like employer paid
medical insurance isn't that a benefit
so the um the the com the component for
uh bet is compensation and Wages that's
paid or accrued
um benefits paid on behalf of employees
I'm not too sure okay yeah um yeah
right not including benefits it's
compensation and wages accrued or paid
so let's say you accruing a bonus for
someone
maybe I don't know yeah right other
questions over here uh representative
has a question
thank you I hadn't thought about this
before
or is a credit carry forward
have we ever looked at how much of our
credit carry forward we always worry
about is excess bet
the that that is a different type of
credit carry forward the credit care for
I believe that uh you're referring to is
this is the CCO limitation of the 500 to
50 that is Money Paid in by the company
the taxpayers that is kept on account
with us right X extra money so-called
that instead of refunding it to say okay
yeah you guys keep it for a while
um and then whereas this uh this credit
is a bad credit uh essentially it's the
bad taxes that um that is due on the
business Enterprise that's compared to
the BPT and then if there's you have
more bad
taxes you just keep on account to be
used against the BPT
so it's a totally different company it's
different yeah
very simply it would the BET credit that
is available to be used against BBT if
it's if it's not used against BBT it's
not going to be refunded
because it was an actual liability that
was paid under the bet so it's counted
separately than the CCO that Keane
mentioned where we were tracking
payments at a business received for
which they didn't have a liability but
so there's no refunding of the excess
pet credit
yes go ahead
um
just to understand the distinction
between non-profit and
501c3 are things like some hospitals are
I know they're non-profit what what is
happening with the bet for those in in
some private schools so a 501c3 is a an
IRS
designation you the the non-profit
organization has to apply for a 501c3
classification
uh just because you call yourself a
non-profit doesn't mean you're you're a
501c3
um therefore if you're just a non-profit
without the 501c3 you'll be still be
subject to the bet
um
that's not addressing my question so you
have to tell me a little more about what
makes a 501
so an organization that's tell me about
hospitals and private schools hospitals
and private schools are traditionally
501c3 organizations the majority of
non-profit organizations are 501c3
organizations to Keane's point though
there is a long list of IRS designations
that are not 501c3s there's 501c1 C2 C8
C9 C4s Etc the majority though of what
you would think of as a non-profit is
likely a 501c3 and would not be subject
to bet
so just to make sure that what I'm
thinking in my head I'm not trying to be
political or anything thinking in my
head is correct
so when hospitals in private schools
have for example you know whoever's at
the top of the organizational chart are
receiving salaries of like 350
000 a year or more that the bet is not
being applied to them that's correct
representative ulrey has a question uh
not really a question just amplify on
that
um
there are I think
501cs on the IRS code
uh for example uh the Masons our 501c10
the Knights of Columbus are 501 C8 uh
some schools are
501c4s I believe
um
which is different
and it depends on what you do with your
money and how you do it whether or not
you show a profit
as to whether or not it becomes then
subject to the BET and these guys get to
play judge and jury on that
representative fellows so my take of
what I think I'm hearing is that they
don't get to be judge and jury because
the IRS has already made that they're
the ones making that decision
just point of information we also have a
New Hampshire entity the charitable
trust division of the Department of
Justice that is also monitoring
non-profits to make sure that they're
staying in compliance just so you know
we have a state arm as well
representative ulrey has a question and
within the charitable trust anyone who
says that they are is whether they are
or not
is that opinion or fact I don't know any
questions on this side of the room
okay back to you okay
and uh so moving on to slide 17 uh this
is another breakdown of the um showing
the the filers on the left hand side by
entity type and then the percentage of
bad taxes on the right hand side and
once again the theme is still the same
you'll see that the water's edge files
is 5.8 percent whereas they bring in
50.3 percent of the BET taxes
uh the the next slide is uh the similar
slides to the BPT however this is just
for the bed and this is the triangle the
reverse triangle and you see that um for
uh you know for some of bad tax bad
taxes uh from uh 100 400 000 onwards to
a million dollars so that range is about
155 million dollars in in bad taxes uh
but then the the percentage of uh
the filers in that uh in that for that
kind of Revenue it's only 3.7 of the um
of the the filers that brings in about
155 million dollars out of the 216
million dollars that that's brought in
and the um the next graph here is the
10-year trend for bad Revenue
um and you see here it seems to be a
more drastic change on fiscal year 20
the dip is more drastic if you remember
with the BPT BPT chart that's because uh
as we mentioned earlier the uh the bad
tax is based out of the dividends pay
the compensation paid and and so
compensation being a majority part of
the element for bet uh you see that
covet year fiscal year 20
um that's probably the the main reason
for that
so just to clarify so as people are
getting pay raises and paying get paid
more money businesses pay more on that
the BET tax will probably likely go up
yes
sorry representative mommy thanks before
we leave these two is there a way to
combine the inverted triangles for
b-e-t and BPT
since we always consider the business
taxes
together
when we're doing the work
it might be interesting to look at that
it's probably I mean it the numbers are
extreme enough that
it'd probably not change much but
right going over to slide 20 so this is
a combined bet and BBT Revenue Trend
analysis for 10 years and you see that
the chart is it's similar to the the two
charts before the line charts before
um and once again you see the dip in
fiscal year 20
um and uh the dotted line is the
fiscalia 23 plan Revenue
okay
the
okay the next slide slide 21 uh just to
summarize the different business tax
changes uh the statute changes that that
was implemented on the business profits
uh the business taxes in total the first
bullet point is the market-based
sourcing that's what tax will appears
ending on or after December 31 2021.
market-based sourcing essentially this
impacts um business organizations that
conduct business activities inside and
outside of New Hampshire so market-based
Outsourcing is the terms of
apportionment of sales other than sales
of tangible personal property so a
business organization could have
two kinds of sales either sales selling
tangible personal property like selling
widgets and stuff like that and another
type of sales is sale selling of uh
sales other than tangible personal
property
historically what New Hampshire was
doing is the uh the sourcing was based
on cost of performance sourcing so prior
to tax year ending December 3122 not 21
New Hampshire was using cost of
performance sourcing where we see where
is the plural plurality of the cost of
Performing that that income producing
activity and there that would be where
it's sourced to now in for tax year
December 3121 that has all changed to
market-based sourcing so we now see
where the market is for the sale of the
uh not uh other than tangible personal
property
the next bullet point is the cap on
credit carryover so as we were talking
earlier there's this uh business
organized business organizations pay in
their estimates and then the they
estimate the amount of taxes that they
would owe and then when the father
return potentially maybe they might not
needed to have paid that much so then
there's this credit on account the tax
the taxpayers could either request that
money back for a refund or say no you
just keep it for next year's credit
apply to next year's taxes so this is
the credit carryover uh item that we
were talking about earlier and for
textures uh tax periods ending on or
after December 31 22 that amount is kept
at 500 percent of the total tax
liability of the particular taxpayer uh
so this would sort of encourage and you
see the the trend of 500 going down to
250 and you're going down to 100 so this
is trying to persuade the taxpayers to
not keep their
um
money with the state and and then you
know and more muscle to have them take
that money out and refund because the
potential issue is that uh whenever the
tax payment uh say okay this year I want
to
get a refund and so we may not be
prepared for that kind of scenario in
terms of a revenue focus a revenue
forecasting so this helps us
predict better in terms of the the
revenue that we would be seeing in the
future
representative Almy header a question
here's her hand up do you still have a
question
um
I don't know how much we ought to maybe
just get into these more thoroughly
later
but market-based sourcing happened
um
two two years ago essentially for us and
we've got some kind of idea that
of what it may have done to us
but also I think people need to
understand better what market-based
sourcing is it's the repairman
who sits in New Hampshire and does a lot
of work in Massachusetts
but he gets all his equipment together
in New Hampshire he does his his
Contracting into from New Hampshire and
Etc and he was paying taxes in New
Hampshire on that rather than in
Massachusetts so now with market-based
sourcing most of his clients are in
Massachusetts and he's paying
Massachusetts instead
and somebody who sits in Massachusetts
like our septic guy does uh and comes up
to New Hampshire to work
he would be paying to New Hampshire
whereas before he was paying to
Massachusetts
yeah
but yeah we've gone over this a couple
times but we can keep talking about it
this is a good time to do it because in
very soon order we're going to actually
be putting a pencil to paper yeah okay
but all of these things like the credit
carry forward every one of them has a
complicated story behind it and I'm
worried about getting through everything
yeah before noon well we've talked about
that before but we can keep talking
about it do you want to cover the carry
forward because I know you and
representative major worked really hard
on that basically forcing people to get
returns so we don't have a huge
liability on the books right
yeah feel free to explain that if
now this was basically representative
Majors I worried about the single sales
Factor he worried about the credit carry
forward
um
and the credit carry forward on our
books is about 300 million at this point
it's been growing quite a lot in the
last
five years ten years on and essentially
it's money that we owe to the businesses
about half of it on turns over every
year as the businesses that kept the
money there use it for their estimated
payments
and I frankly don't understand how we
account for them when we're figuring out
how much our estimated payments have
gone one way or the other but anyway on
and
on the other half we don't know what it
is which is why I was jumping on the BET
before that I thought maybe I finally
had an answer but
but uh
we're worried that it could be
that in a major recession or even a
semi-recession where people are still
coming out of the covet era that a lot
of businesses would come back to us at
the same time and would say
I want my money back
and the treasury might have a lot of
trouble with that
so
um and we've been worrying about it for
a long time and doing nothing about it
because it's expensive it could be
expensive
um
one of the things that I've been
worrying about lately is
we've got this schedule that we put
together and it was on purpose that we
were going to take just the businesses
with the most credit carry forward first
and they weren't going to cost us a
whole lot
so that we could see how this was going
to go and then in 25 we would hit the
Vise a little bit
harder and more of them would have to
take back their money
and by 27 probably the finance committee
would have intervened and said okay
let's slow this down a little
but but
um
what could also be happening right now
if some businesses are struggling
is that they and they're in the 250
percent one
that they would think oh maybe I'll
start right now
so that I'll have some more money to
operate with the next year or two
because I don't know what's going to
happen 24.
so um that's that's a very helpful
background did you have a question
representative jinnegan thank you madam
chair uh just a clarification
um representative almi stated that
there's about 300 million I just want is
that correct that is roughly correct 300
315 320
um it's somewhere in there okay
so
talking generally about these
legislative changes
um we kind of hit on the large ones
which is market-based sourcing the cap
on the CCO the last one I just wanted to
mention that's notable here is the
single sales Factor apportionment as
representative almi mentioned
um
under
we used to operate under what's called
three-factor apportionment where if you
are a business that operates in multiple
States and you have your pie of of
profit and you need to divide that pie
up into the various states that you
operate New Hampshire would say tell me
what you have for payroll in New
Hampshire tell me what you have for
property and tell me what you have for
sales and that those are the factors
that we would use to determine how much
of your pie you should pay taxes on here
in New Hampshire
for taxable periods ending on or after
December 31st of 22 now we only care
what you have for sales into New
Hampshire we no longer care about how
much property or how much payroll
obviously payroll is still taxed under
bet but you're apportionment how you
divide that pie only matters based on
how much you have for sales in New
Hampshire so that's a change to how
you're going to divide your pie for
those businesses that operate in
multiple States
okay
representative ulrey has a question
yeah just to put that in practical
application
I'm a
Construction Company
located in the Border Town
I do most of my work building big tall
buildings in Boston
most of my sales are in Boston but my
employees all live in New Hampshire
just work that out for me right so under
three Factor apportionment you would
look at what your payroll was to
employees you would look at where your
property was so if you owned property on
a Border Town to house all of your large
construction equipment and then we'd
look to where your sales were
now we're only going to look to where
your sales were so it is likely in your
scenario that most of your profit would
be taxable in Massachusetts and not here
in New Hampshire and so in your example
that business would pay less tax in New
Hampshire than they had been previously
representative MS
just to take that a step further
is different for the BET for that same
business which may have a very
significant bet component if
substantial numbers of employees are
located here you're still going to
apportion kind of the same way but yes
yes
it it gets complicated
um but yes you're gonna your your bet is
still on your payroll here in New
Hampshire but if those employees are
working in Massachusetts doesn't matter
where you cut the check from it matters
where they're working right so if
they're working in Massachusetts then
it's not likely that you would be um
they would be subject to bet because
they're not New Hampshire employees
yes
um I guess the other question we're all
waiting for information on how this is
playing out yes so that's what I was
going to get to do okay are you ready
okay so this is um if you go to slide 22
I'm not going to go through this in
detail because it is a little bit
complicated and just keeping an eye on
the time
what I wanted to just generally explain
is how this is all going to factor into
the revenue estimating that we're going
to work on with all of you
so on slide 22 we've included some of
the larger changes that we just
discussed the market-based sourcing the
CCO cap the single sales factor and then
there is a small change to
the nol calculation
I've included here what the impact of
those tax changes look like over the
next few fiscal years so kind of the
timing of those tax changes when will we
see those tax changes come into effect
what we're going to do with you for
Revenue estimating to help make all of
these complications hopefully a little
bit simpler is when we come to you we're
going to give you estimates for any of
these tax changes that we haven't fully
realized the effect of yet
so if a tax change has been fully
implemented and would have been seen in
revenues we're not going to have to talk
about it we're just going to work with
you on those tax changes that we haven't
seen the full impact in our revenues yet
again in a way to hopefully make it
simpler and we'll do the the legwork for
you about what we haven't seen yet and
what we think that impact is going to be
so I know it feels like there there's
been a lot of changes over the past few
years and it can be overwhelming but
we're going to try to make it as simple
as possible and just talk through those
changes for which we haven't seen the
full impact yet in our revenues
sound good representative fellows
so they're
um going back to page 21 so the
market-based sourcing and the single
sales Factor those came about because a
bill was passed yep those are changes
that came about through legislation
correct do you know
um
do do you have any references
we can get you the build numbers they're
included in our technical information
releases that we do every year based on
the legislative session so we can get
you that information
representative spilsbury
thank you madam chair do we accrue and
ultimately pay an interest liability to
those who carry um
carry over there
we would pay interest only we have 90
days to pay out a refund after it's been
requested
so the 300 plus million carries with it
an undefined interest liability
potentially potentially but as long as
we pay out those refunds in a timely
manner from the date of request there
wouldn't be a significant liability
okay so we sorry I apologize I missed a
hand representative all me
thank you I'd just like to say this
committee agreed with market-based
sourcing
and you thought that it probably wasn't
going to change stuff much
and and we'll find out and we will find
out we won't find out about any of this
stuff but market-based sourcing on you
told us that once it had been in place
for enough time we'd be able to get a
clearer estimate of what single sales
Factor would do to us and this committee
fought tooth and nail in the budget uh
and lost
to of to push single sales factor out to
26.
right so to represent of elmy's Point
um when the legislature had the desire
to move from the cost of performance
method of apportionment for sales and
services and intangibles excuse me to
market-based sourcing we were unable to
develop a revenue impact for that
because we didn't know where the
customers were we knew where the
services were being performed that's how
it worked under cost of performance but
we didn't have any data that told us
where the customers were which is how
the apportionment was going to work
under market-based sourcing so we had no
Revenue impact no ability to estimate
that Revenue impact
going from three Factor apportionment to
single sales Factor we can do that math
because we know what the sales factor is
because they're currently reporting it
to us with the two other factors
the problem there was that single sales
Factor was coming right on the heels of
the change to market-based sourcing and
so the revenue impacts that we estimated
for the move to single sales was under
the cost of performance method so
because these two changes are happening
in quick secession we don't have the
data yet and didn't have it at the time
that the legislation was being
contemplated to actually estimate the
revenue impact
representative ulery
thank you and thank you for the
dedication to the changes that we're
making
sometimes mind-boggling the question I
have going back to the example that I
provided and there's a couple of
companies down where I'm located to do
that how do they become Massachusetts
employees when they clock in in Hudson
so it's it's hard to talk about specific
examples because each business is going
to operate differently so those are you
know where they clock in where they do
their work where they're paid where
their home base is considered do they
have a home base do they not these are
all things that would factor into their
actual liability so for these businesses
it's kind of it's difficult to talk
about exactly how it would work without
a lot of additional detail
this also applies to an other
legislation we have coming up regarding
income taxes or uh Massachusetts trying
to take money from New Hampshire
employees which is one of the reasons I
want to hit this
uh question uh a little a little more
deeply uh
so
it would be interesting if if we got a
list of that that we could apply not
only to this discussion into estimating
but also to the income tax issue that we
have coming up we can kind of list out
for you factors that would be considered
under where the employee would be
considered taxable if that's acceptable
Madam chair
thank you sure
okay how do we feel on business taxes I
apologize we have another question
representative Ames I'm sorry uh
thinking about this for a a business
that
is selling into several States
or even just one are you interacting
with the tax departments on the other
states I mean there needs to be a
uniform approach to this that's a good
point so yes we have exchange agreements
with other states we routinely interact
with them
um but to your point one of the reasons
that brought about this change
especially to market-based sourcing was
that when states are not uniform in
their methodologies businesses can pay
tax say on services that they perform
here in New Hampshire they can pay tax
here in New Hampshire under cost of
performance and then if their customer
is in Massachusetts and Massachusetts is
a market-based sourcing state they're
going to pay tax in Massachusetts on
that same service
so until the states or if ever the
states are totally uniform in how they
apportion income there are instances
where business can pay the tax in New
Hampshire for work and pay tax in
Massachusetts for that same work and
that was one of the reasons why
market-based sourcing that shift to
market-based sourcing came about here in
New Hampshire because many of our
neighboring states are also market-based
sourcing States and so this should
decrease
um the instances where New Hampshire
businesses were paying tax on the same
services in two states
okay are we feeling okay on business
taxes we got a half hour to get through
the rest well and just so we're going to
keep this keep going your questions are
excellent the information you're
providing is excellent and then they're
going to come back and then we're going
to do Revenue estimates and we're going
to have we're going to make sure we give
this agency as much time as we need so
we can talk through each piece again
okay sure
thank you okay so we'll move pretty
quickly I think through the rest
business taxes are by far the most
complicated so we should be able to move
pretty quickly
um and again most of this information
was previously provided so hopefully
some of it is sounding at least a little
bit familiar uh the meals and rooms are
the meals and rentals tax is it eight
and a half percent tax on meals room
rentals and motor vehicle rentals the
taxes paid by you the consumer at the
time that you eat that meal the operator
who operates the restaurant where you
might be dining is responsible for
collecting that tax and remitting it to
the department on a monthly basis
doing so in a manner compliant with the
statute meaning on-time filing allows
those operators to retain three percent
for the work that they do for collecting
the tax on the state's behalf
returns are filing filed on a monthly
basis on the 15th day of the month for
the following for the prior month and
electronically electronic filing is
available to operators a paper return is
not required so operators have the
opportunity to just file electronically
and not worry about sending us paper on
a monthly basis
on side 24 there are two
amounts that come out of the meals and
rentals tax on a monthly basis that I
just wanted to flag for you on the left
is the school building Aid this is
school building Aid Debt Service
for fiscal 23 the total amount for the
year is just over seven million dollars
and we transfer over just half a million
out of the general fund on a monthly
basis
more notably on the right is the
municipal Revenue fund and this as we
mentioned at the prior presentation this
began in fiscal 2022
and 30 percent of m r uh from the most
recent fiscal year is distributed to
cities and towns via this Municipal
Revenue fund
amounts are transferred on a monthly
basis out of the general fund and into
this dedicated fund
in fiscal 22 the amount was just over
100 million 100.1 million and in fiscal
23 we will be transferring 121 million
out of the general fund into this
dedicated fund again this happens on a
monthly basis right now in fiscal 23
it's about 10 million dollars each month
the amount per month fluctuates based on
the amount of Revenue that we typically
receive in that month
so just note that when you're comparing
m r to fiscal 21 and prior we were not
taking this money out so you'll see on
the slides it looks like m r has
actually gone down when it act when it
hasn't the the reflection of this
Municipal Revenue transfer is looking
like a reduction
in m r
um on the third bullet on the right hand
side
I'm just showing what the municipal
Revenue transfer used to be so the
amount used to be 40 however it had been
capped for a number of years and these
amounts were paid out at the end of the
year it was not done via a monthly
Revenue transfer so grow or so m r
amounts again for fiscal 21 in Prior
will not reflect these m r distributions
um but they will in 22 and 23. so
comparing year to year
we will work with you when we're doing
Revenue estimates to actually estimate
the gross revenue that would be received
and then we'll take out these transfers
to make it simple and make it more
um easier to compare prior years
representative thank you madam chair
just a quick question uh you say the
amounts were capped they were capped at
roughly 22 percent I believe yeah that's
roughly the amount so even though the
statute said 40 percent legislation via
hb2 frequently as you can see for a
number of years capped the amount at
what had been distributed pre in the
previous years
thank you
representative Phyllis
um thank you I have a question about the
school building Aid that so where the
state is paying off debt it borrowed
money to fund the schools that were
built does are we finished
um paying off that debt when we get to
2030 that's correct okay thank you
for the current round of debt if there
was additional debt that the state
chooses to fund in this manner then it
could extend beyond 2030 but right now
the amounts would be fully paid in 2030.
okay slide 25 this just shows the
breakdown between meals rooms and motor
vehicle rentals you'll see the vast
majority of m r revenue is received from
food
on slide 26 I think this may have been
mentioned at our prior presentation but
just looking at the m r Revenue that's
generated by county
um so you'll see at the top we have the
various counties going from left to
right you will see
um we're moving from largest to smallest
so Rockingham County generates the
largest amount of m r Revenue this is
for fiscal 22 at
131.2 million Sullivan County being the
smallest at 4.5 million
at the bottom you'll see the breakdown
by county
and then broken down by meals rooms in
motor vehicle a couple of things I would
point out here you'll see Stratford
Rockingham Sullivan County mostly meals
if you move over to Hillsboro you'll see
that there's quite a large amount
comparatively of motor vehicle rentals
that would be the rental cars at the
airport
and then moving over to Carol and koa's
counties you'll see that there's in koas
almost an equal distribution between
meals and rooms Carol has slightly more
meals than rooms but you'll just see how
the the components by County will vary
thank you
representative Russia has a question
so
percentage of this room's
tax that we're collecting is
attributable to short-term rentals
yes and no
um so when
an operator
um
receives a license from the Department
they self-identify what sort of business
they are so are they a full-service
hotel are they a full service rent
restaurant are they a fast food
restaurant
um short-term rentals is not technically
a category but they typically fall under
what we would call rental agents and so
those would be either your online travel
platforms or your local real estate
agent that also has a rental business
and you can rent homes you know vacation
homes Etc through there so we can we can
give you that breakdown if that's
helpful
yeah follow up thank you I I think it
would be helpful because you know
there's a lot of
discussion right now about limiting
short-term rentals or putting
concessions on short-term rentals and um
you know I think it would help our
communities anyway to get a better idea
of
whether whether that's something you can
do in applic just in the application
without the legislature's involvement
just to get a better idea of really
how much of our money is coming from
from that I know where I'm from it's a
topic of discussion but I'm afraid that
it's
you know it might have unintended
consequences you know when it comes time
to so it would get it would give the
municipalities a little more data sure
so I can just looking at December
um
meals and rentals Revenue that we
received in January rental agents were
about just under 1.2 million of the
total
in December of 21 in December of 22 they
were 1.5 million so we there's
definitely a year-over-year increase
there of over 25 percent
um and then just to give you some
context
full service hotels which I think
generally would be kind of what you
anticipate like a Marietta Hampton Inn
you know a full-service Hotel
um in December of 21 they were 2.5
million of m r revenue and December of
22 they were 2.8 million so they saw an
increase of just under 13 percent
just to give you some context
um in terms of what a full-service Hotel
population versus this rental agent
population again it's not totally
foolproof because it's a self-identified
code but I think we can see that
definitely that short-term rental or
rental agent category grew year over
year more than the full service hotels
did and I think that's kind of
consistent with what we're hearing
generally
you're welcome
representative homie
thank you um
the gentleman asked on about
municipalities and I think it's
important to point out that we don't
know for municipalities because there
may be an owner in a town that has no
restaurants at all who owns Six
restaurants in the region and he reports
them from his town or from his
accountants town
so that's a good point so it's
um we've been asked previously about
that distribution to municipalities that
I mentioned how that calculation is done
and that is currently done based on
population so the we take the total
population of the state we figure out
how much population is in each town and
that's how the amount is divvied up
we've been asked well can't you
distribute couldn't the state distribute
the revenue to municipalities based on
where the revenue is generated
and to representative Ami's point the
answer to that really is no because you
do have an option as an m r fire filer
to file a Consolidated return to file
one return per month rather than five
returns per month and so when you file
that one return per month you're going
to put your one address on it it might
be the address of your headquarters but
you might have locations in five or six
different towns and so it's difficult
for us to know without additional
reporting if the operators
um if we're required to do so we could
break that information down but based on
the information we have right now we
don't know
exactly how much revenue is generated in
each town so when we do this chart based
on County
you there may be some
um
we don't know for sure that all of the
revenue is necessarily generated in that
county if it was a Consolidated return
but at the county basis it's probably
pretty accurate but we can't go down to
a town level basis because we could have
five restaurants reporting under say
just the Manchester location for
instance
representative fellows and then
representative oh thank you
um I just had a question on your
definition of short-term rentals and if
you think
um there are
entities that are
maybe doing short-term rentals that were
missing out on the revenue that maybe we
maybe we should be collecting so under
the m r statute
um rentals room rentals that are taxable
are are stays shorter than six months so
that's what we kind of use as a
short-term definition per the statute if
you are renting an apartment for a year
that is not subject to tax under the
meals and rentals tax that's a long-term
rental
in terms of are there short-term rentals
that we are missing out on there's
multiple ways if I own a second home and
I want to rent that out to people to
come up to hold Earnest to go skiing
um I can do that in a number of ways I
can do that via an online platform and
they will collect and remit the tax on
my behalf I can do it through my local
real estate or rental agent and that
same scenario would apply they would
collect and remit the tax on my behalf
or I can put it out on Facebook to my
friends and I would need to have a meals
and rentals operator license I would
need to collect that tax from the people
that stay in my home and remit it to the
state
um there is a requirement in the law
that if I am doing option three where
I'm renting it out myself and I'm
putting it out even say an ad in the
newspaper that I include my meals and
rentals tax license so that folks know
that I am licensed and collecting in the
remitting the tax
um we will use those advertisements to
help identify people that may or not may
or may not be following the statute
if the rental agent if they're using a
rental agent in that rental agent is not
in New Hampshire do would we still
collect they would still need to have a
license yep if they're renting property
so if it's if they're on the border and
they're in Massachusetts or On the
Border in Maine but they're renting
property in New Hampshire they would
need to be licensed
correct represent Oliver did you have
something
yeah just to follow up immediately or
operating an online service in
California renting properties correct
correct so the your online travel
platforms etc those it doesn't matter
that they're not physically here if
they're renting property here then they
need to be licensed I was just going to
correct me if I'm wrong but just to put
a face on the difficulty in the signing
to towns you have uh franchise
operations uh there's a couple of large
families that have several large Dunkin
Donut franchises great example of 15
different stores uh McDonald's even
um the great Foods chain correct which
has what four different restaurants
correct uh are four different restaurant
Brands Brands yes and 20 some odd
restaurants they're in different towns
all over the state so they're because
they're filing on a monthly basis
um they're going to file one return
yeah they're gonna file 12 returns but
if they had to file by location or break
that information out by location it
would be significantly more work for
them yeah I just
put a face to the correct good example
okay slide 27 this is a chart you've
seen before in the prior presentation
this is just the 10-year Trend
um of m r Revenue again this is after
the municipal Revenue fund transfer so
it looks like we have a decrease in
revenue from fiscal year 21 to 22 but
fiscal 22 transferred 100.1 million to
the municipal Revenue fund so gross
revenue in 22 was actually
407.3 million
so again we will add these back in and
we'll grow the gross and then take it
out for Revenue estimating purposes to
make it a little bit easier for all of
you
then we take it out then we add it back
in
okay I'll set on m r
okay
all right so uh moving on to the next
text type is tobacco tax so tobacco is
tax uh a few different ways one is if
it's uh the tax stamps and the other if
it's taxed as in other tobacco products
so for tax stamps it is a tax at uh 1.78
per pack of 20s 20 cigarettes and uh
2.23 cents per pack of 25 and then
65.03 percent of the wholesale price for
other tobacco products except for
e-cigarettes e-cigarettes depending on
the type of e-cigarettes it's going to
be taxed differently as well so
e-cigarettes the close system tax rate
is 0.3 per point three cents per
millimeter on the volume of liquid or
other substance containing nicotine and
the open system is taxed at eight
percent of the wholesale price of the
container of the liquid
now currently premium cigars are exempt
from taxation uh premium cigars are
defined as a
cigars that's made by hand uh with
natural tobacco leave weighs more than
three pounds per 1000 cigars and it's
kept in the humidor tax on tobacco
products as a direct tax on consumer at
retail but it's collected pre-collected
and paid by the wholesaler so
essentially it's a tax on on the
consumer
um and for packages of uh 20 and or 25
cigarettes payment of tax is evidenced
by a wholesaler purchase of tobacco tax
stamps and that's a fixed to the the
package of the the cigarette
representative Valerie
thank you
the question is you get nine percent
income from uh otps
what is the cost to administer that tax
versus the revenue generated
um
thank you
well um
I guess that's another rhetorical
question
I appreciate just the opportunity to
bring that forward because the cost to
administer collection of taxes is also a
fact
a factor into the cost of administering
generation
it says negative factor but
I will say one thing about the the
tobacco tax is that the tax is collected
at the wholesaler level
not so that to your point about the cost
to administer it if the tax was if it
was the retailers that were collecting
and remitting the tax that would
obviously be the bottom of the period it
pyramid and would be a much larger
number of taxpayers that we were dealing
with so where the taxes really collected
and remitted at the wholesale level it's
a smaller Universe of of businesses that
we're interacting with
to your point if that makes sense okay
representative liply
thank you
I was wondering if and I'm not sure if
this is a question for you or for the
committee I was wondering if there was a
technical reason we don't tax the
premium cigars
like how did that it's not a technical
reason that is a policy decision that
this committee has made for many years
we have a bill about that I believe
coming up so we'll revisit that in
Greater detail get the history on that
thank you all the questions yes
representative fellows yep thank you
um do you think that people are buying
their tobacco products over the internet
and avoiding this tax so the tax would
not be avoided over the Internet there
is a statutory requirement that if you
do purchase
um as a consumer you purchase products
over the Internet or in some other maybe
legal way for which the
um tax has not already been collected
and remitted on your behalf we do have a
form that you would fill out and pay the
tax on those products do you are not
avoiding the tax by purchasing on the
internet you have an obligation to pay
that tax
correct
all right and um so
um I guess we can oh so can move on to
the next slide
all right okay
uh tobacco tax and this is a pie chart
as uh representative ulery pointed out
uh the uh OTP it represents nine percent
of the total tobacco tax revenue whereas
the bulk of the tobacco tax revenue
comes from Tech stamps
and moving on to slide 30 this is a
tobacco Tech stamp Revenue graph and it
shows on a fiscal year basis how much of
the tobacco Tax and Revenue is being
collected and you see here uh there is
Ace fiscal year 19 it's slight dipped
there and then slightly going up in
fiscal year 20 and fiscated 21 that's it
significant increase there and that is
uh potentially could be two reasons one
is the debt coincides with the
Massachusetts ban on
flavored uh flavor tobacco including
mentholated cigarettes and with that so
since the those kinds of cigarettes are
not being cannot be sold in
Massachusetts a lot we received the
elasticity of the sales a lot of the
users are purchasing it here in in New
Hampshire
and um
moving on to the next slide slide 31 and
this is the OTP Revenue so this sort of
puts some kind of um more meat into the
question that was asked by
representative early you see that the
revenue for OTP essentially is actually
increasing so uh if if the cost to
administer Remains the Same you'll see a
higher return to the cost as the EU goes
by
and next moving on to the next slide
slide 32 this is a 10-year Revenue Trend
with tobacco taxes and once again the uh
probably the only significant item to
attend to note here is that fiscal year
20 that the Massachusetts ban what's
happening there showing an upward
trajectory of Revenue uh in fiscal year
21.
and you do see a slight decline from
fiscal year 21 to fiscal year 22 most
likely it's because uh people are being
a bit more health conscious at that time
and people are sort of coming back to
the office to work and so the
restrictions in terms of smoking and
using tobacco products when when they're
at the office versus when they're at
home during the covid-19 time
foreign moving on to the next slide
slide 33 uh this is just a slight to
show the the ranking of uh the the tax
rates on the tobacco products and then
also the sort of the um the unless the
illegal
smuggling of cigarettes and can be
consumed in that state and you see that
New Hampshire ranks really low in terms
of uh Revenue loss from uh uh smuggle
cigarettes consumption
representative Valerie so you're
referring to cigarette smuggled in to
New Hampshire not the truckloads going
to New York City that's that's right yes
it is in terms of revenue revenue to the
state yeah
I just want to make one last point if I
can on the tobacco tax
um in the monthly reports that we send
to you
um you will see one of our reports shows
tobacco tax stamp sales so you can see
literally the number of stamps that we
sell each month and each one of those
stamps goes on a bottom bottom of a pack
of cigarettes before it's sold you'll
also see in the bottom part of that
report is the receivable Bond balance
when the cigarette or tobacco
wholesalers purchase those tobacco tax
stamps from us they're able to purchase
those on Bond and so they don't need to
make a payment at the time of purchase
they need to make a payment within 30
days so at the end of each month we'll
show you how much revenue is kind of
outstanding for the next month because
it can be a little bit of foreshadowing
into the revenue that we'll receive in
the subsequent month so that's the kind
of the difference what you're seeing at
the top is the gross amount of stamps
stamps that we sold and at the bottom is
okay how much money from those stamp
sales are we going to expect to see in
Revenue in the subsequent month
anything else on Tobacco
yeah yeah
yes premium cigars yes
um real estate transfer tax we've
um talked about this before this is the
tax on the sale granting and transfer of
property real property or interest in
property it is split between the buyer
and the seller each paying 75 cents per
hundred dollars
um this is the effectuation of this
taxes done at the registry of deeds and
each County retains four percent as a
commission
um on slide 35 we've talked about this
before in terms of how we kind of
forecast Rhett revenue and there's
really two pieces to it right you need
transactions to occur in order to uh
receive the revenue but the value of
that transaction determines how much
revenue we receive so we can go through
a period of time where we're seeing a
decline in the number of transactions
but if the value of those sales is
increasing we can actually see ret
remain the same or even go up so in
fiscal 22 this shows you the average
monthly percent of transactions and the
average monthly percent of Revenue by
County so I would just I'll just
highlight two counties if you look at
Grafton County on average they're just
under 10 percent of the number of
transactions
but there's seven percent of the tax
going down to Rockingham County they're
20 percent of their transactions but 28
and a half percent of the tax so
that's kind of how those two pieces
interact with each other so as we move
through the next couple of months and
maybe year or two where we may see a
decline in the number of sales
well which we even have been seeing up
to this point
the impact on Rhett is really going to
be based on the value of those sales so
we are showing that on slide 36 you can
see that we've had a number of good
years now significant increase in ret in
fiscal 21 and fiscal 22.
um you may have noticed at least for 22
you can see and 21 we're we're above
fiscal 23 Revenue plan and through
December of fiscal 23 we had been
significantly above plan you may have
noticed in the
January revenue Focus the January came
in
pretty close to plan so we may be seeing
a bit of cool of cooling in the real
estate market plan did anticipate that
to happen to some extent
I will note though that for
Revenue received in January which is for
December transactions we received 16.2
million
this January that's compared to 25.8
last January however looking at
pre-covered levels the highest we had
seen was about 14 million so 16 million
is still good Revenue compared to
pre-covered levels it's just less than
what we've seen over the past two fiscal
years representative thank you thank you
for taking my question
Um this can be impacted I believe also
by some anomalies depending if there's
some large sales just wanted to know
about that is true so if there are large
sales if there's large properties that
sell large apartment complexes those
sorts of things we do get weekly reports
of all real estate transactions within
the state and we will monitor for those
to make sure we know whether or not what
we're seeing is the result of an anomaly
or a very large transaction or if it's
really just an increase in the Baseline
so thank you that's a great point
representative Oliver
and if I'm correct
when you're transferring from a trust a
revocable trust there's because there's
no cash value involved in that transfer
there's no uh rent paid uh to to refi
your home that's correct that's correct
and so there are a number of exceptions
to the red that are listed out in the
statute
um and we can certainly dive into that
with the committee and a future
presentation if you'd like
representative Phyllis
um do business long-term leases do those
are those subject to this tax it's it's
when the there is a transfer in either
the interest of the property or an
actual sale of the property so if it's
just a lease then that wouldn't be
included here
foreign
moving on to the next text type is the
interest in dividends tax
um the right now the the for tax peers
ending on or after December 3123 the tax
rate is at four percent and with current
uh statute that tax rate is going to be
decreasing year over year and uh right
up to one percent in the tax periods
ending December 31 26 and will be repeal
effective gen 1 of 27. pardon my
Interruption is I just looked at the
time and I need to make sure folks get a
time for lunch and you have quite a bit
of a presentation left
may I propose we have you back maybe
next Monday for a little bit to continue
with this maybe we'll have some of these
thoughts and questions formed and we can
do a little bit more
before we start putting pencil to paper
is that are you open to that Chris I
don't know if you have any time to maybe
see if we can have them back on next
Monday the 13th just maybe for an hour
and a half or something
that way because I don't want to I don't
want anyone to feel rushed and we still
have a lot of material and you might
have more follow-up questions on things
we've already covered does that work
okay
and I think that's a good idea because
we're not coming in until the week after
next to actually start our Revenue
estimate right so we've got next week to
to do that so that's totally fine that
would be great yeah we know what we all
we lost a big day with that snow day so
now we're playing catch-up and we have a
lot of folks that are kind of new to
these topics so you know there's no need
to rush through this great presentation
and you know I think having you come
back we'll have some even more refined
questions for you so that would be great
thank you so much so we'll see you next
week okay great awesome so we'll break
for lunch
um and just heads up we do have another
four or five bills that we need to take
up in terms of hearings so I'm looking
at next Wednesday which I believe is the
15th so on Tuesday so Monday we're going
to have a presentation and maybe any
other follow-up presentations Tuesday
we'll have house session and then the
governor's budget address then Wednesday
we'll take up the remaining bills that
we haven't had hearings on and some of
those bills will deal with some of these
tax policies policies we're hearing now
so for example tobacco tax so dra will
be here to help us drill down at that
time as well right okay and then the
following week that's when we're
starting to drill down on the revenue
estimates and there will be some as we
notice from the Department of Justice
today on that tobacco suit we probably
don't need him to come back we have all
the information he can give us so we'll
spend more time the valuable time with
these fine folks because this is where
the bulk of the revenue is
makes sense okay great let's break and
we'll see you back here at one thank you
so much
foreign
the uh the time being just past one
o'clock
um we're gonna get started with the
Department of administrative services
and I'd like to welcome them up
foreign
good afternoon I'm Dana call I'm the
State Comptroller and uh normally I'd
have commissioner Charlie arlinghaus
with me today but he had to get pulled
into another meeting so it'll just be me
today
um I am the director of the division of
accounting services which is part of
administrative services so
I think you have my presentation so I'll
get started
so I was asked to present essentially
the category of other Revenue today as
well as talk a little bit about what Das
does in terms of Revenue reporting
so on page two a little oversight a
little overview of admin services in our
Central oversight role over all things
accounting and again as I mentioned
division of accounting services handles
all Statewide accounting requirements
including the state akfer which is the
annual comprehensive financial report
um so that is the largest of our list of
items but I also provided you a
reference to some of the other external
Financial reports that we prepare
throughout the course of the year
regarding unrestricted revenue on page
three
most of you might be familiar with the
monthly Revenue Focus that's an
unaudited interim financial statement
that we put out just to cut and give a
sense of where we're at during the
course of the fiscal year with
unrestricted revenues
um that report is based on an annual
revenue plan that we prepare at the
beginning of the fiscal year based on
the state budget that gets enacted the
state budget provides an annual plan and
then we work with each agency that
collects the revenue to establish what
month they think that Revenue might
likely come in I know you heard a
detailed presentation for most of the
other agencies including Department of
Revenue theirs is the most the largest
portion and the most important in terms
of timing because they can anticipate
what month they expect the bulk of their
revenues to come in to some degree
so the focus just gives you a an actual
versus uh plan and then if there are
other items that come about through
other legislation outside of the enacted
budget those don't affect the actual
Revenue plan we might footnote those
because it will affect actuals but the
revenue plan that's presented in the
focus is just the budget that gets
established once every two years
so turning to page four
excuse me
I don't know
just a little sense of the timing
beginning with this July 1st when we
have a approved enacted budget
then the next week we'll be issuing our
cash basis Focus for the last month the
last of the the end of the previous
fiscal year which was June and then in
July we also give a preliminary cool
Focus so you get two focuses that month
that tells you sort of how things look
in terms of taking into account timing
adjustments and things that will
ultimately affect the audited financial
statements
and then in July we also as I mentioned
prepare the annual revenue plan
allocating it on a monthly basis going
forward for the ensuing year
in August you can expect to see a cash
basis fisc revenue report for the first
July of the new fiscal year as well as
we release again the annual plan so in
each month you'll get a focus and if
you're on that if you want to be added
to that distribution list we have
contact information through our office
we also posted on the Das website so
that's it's always going to be there as
soon as it goes out and we try to get
those out fairly timely obviously
because it is cash basis so we
essentially know where we end the month
but we have to do some month-end closing
procedures and then we and then we send
that information out to everyone
any questions on the focus the process
I'll move on to page five these are some
of the more significant areas within
other so again others are miscellaneous
category uh in so if you think of the
focus and towards the end of the list of
all the business taxes and everything
else kind of lands in other so I'll give
you a little page six if you want to
turn to the actual numbers
is a history of other and it's not a
line item that's easy to budget for
because it's variable in nature
much of the things that sometimes there
can be one-time items that end up in
other and again it's it's anything that
comes in that's unrestricted so
available to support general fund spend
General and education I should say
combined but this is uh
some of the items again the first line
I'll get into in on the next page that's
really the the miscellaneous but some of
the items are larger and we can sort of
um plan for based on looking at several
years worth of activity so we have um
both reimbursement for indirect costs
which is also referred to as swycap and
post retirement benefits recovery these
are items that support uh we recover
from federal and other sources to
support activities that are generally
funded so for instance my office
accounting services is a centralized
office supports the entire state but any
there are there are federal rules that
allow us to recover some of those costs
from Federal grant grants and other
Revenue sources so what that does is we
prepare we have a whole calculation we
prepare rate agencies we will Bill
agencies they'll pay us on those funds
and that gets collected in unrestricted
other so it's based basically to the
bottom line support of general education
fund spending
those are two of the larger line items
and then I know
Treasurer that the Treasury office will
will talk to you after me about
abandoned property and interest on
surplus funds so those are just
highlighted so you can kind of see the
trend analysis but you'll get more
information from the treasurer on that
and then if you want to switch to pay
turn to page seven this is a little bit
more detail on that miscellaneous other
again these are line items that are
collected at the other agencies so some
of these agencies are presenting to you
separately if they have a an item that's
large enough for us to track we we do
have a
various items that the top section that
we've tracked over the years if you look
at line 25 all other that's basically
everything else that's considered not
tracked it's not predictable it comes in
at different levels so that is about a
hundred other individual Revenue sources
and I've given you detail on that at the
end of the presentation so we have again
these line items you'll see if you've
been on this committee before this
format should look familiar to you and
you'll see that we track these items
year over year as compared to plan
and then really again like other than
the highlighted ones that you're hearing
uh from the other agencies about how to
predict most of these items are
unpredictable
so if there aren't any questions on that
I'll stay on page seven we do have a
question representative Ames yeah
um
so on page six sure
just wondering uh there's a spike and
then indirect cost reimbursement and FY
at least in the five years or so that
are covered here that's
pretty significant
and um
and then also in the miscellaneous other
Revenue says was there anything special
I'm looking for special stuff you know
not particularly
um the the calculation for both indirect
costs and post retirement is on a bit of
a lag schedule so we we have to use
prior year data to submit to the federal
government what a future rate is going
to look like and get that rate approved
so that we can Bill agencies and it can
be built into the enacted budget so some
of it is timing some agencies have might
have something that affects the
collectibility so it might shift in
fiscal years so maybe we might have over
the years sometimes we adjust how we
bill to make it a little bit more
manageable for agencies so nothing in
particular comes to mind in in FY 22
other than we do have
um again there's some lag in in the rate
that gets calculated and there's a piece
of it that's called a roll forward
adjustment that sort of um
will affect a future year but we we've
been trying budgetarily to look at it
over a longer term and smooth that
budget rate so that when the agency gets
their rate that we that admin Services
tells them to budget that it we don't
have these Peaks and valleys so we've
been working towards smoothing that but
I don't think there was anything
specific regarding that year
thank you you're welcome any other
representative fellows
thank you Mr chair
um I have two questions is post
retirement benefit recovery is that
mostly related to health insurance and
my second question is abandoned property
is 18 million dollars but is that what
you show as having available but but
people make claims on it so we the state
doesn't really end up with that much
money
so I'm gonna let the treasurer take the
second question because she's much
better at explaining that than I am
um the post-retirement recovery is
similar it's it's not Health it's
retirement costs and essentially we have
a pool of employees obviously that are
eligible for State retirement and much
I'm sorry it's retired it it's retiree
Health but it's specific to retirees so
not the active employees but retiree
Health costs that get funded in the
general in the admin Services budget so
much of that if it's not direct it's a
little complicated much of it if it's
not direct build we have a line item in
administrative services for retiree
Health costs and what we're doing is
we're recovering a portion of that from
where the person spent their time our
best estimate at how they spent their
time and if they were federally funded
during their course of their time
working here we can recover a portion of
that cost from those Federal Grant so it
works similarly to the Statewide cost
allocation plan which is the indirect
cost recovery this is a specific cost
recovery relating to retiree Health but
retiree health is budgeted the bulk of
it in admin services in a generally
funded accounting unit so we're trying
to recover non-general funds to support
that future cost
so if if you do want there's a little
bit more information on both of those
because I know I really just glossed
over those two line items but page eight
and page nine is a little narrative
explanation as to the nature of those
line items again not particularly we're
trying to smooth out those costs best we
can so there's not a a large variability
year over year but that's the basis
these these two line items have been
around for a very long time so
um
that's why we sort of highlight them in
this other presentation because they are
one of the larger items
represent Rochford
yes thank you Mr chair
um thank you page seven I I going back
to that just want to make sure I'm
reading that right looking at fiscal
year 22 just like uh
lines seven and eight corporate records
fees and Corporate filing fees it looks
like there was a dip in Revenue there
based on what was planned is that am I
reading that correctly
yeah when you're excuse yes you're
looking at actual versus plan for fy22
small yeah so so what what is what is
encompassed into those fees or is that
something that's in
because what is Encompass under those
fees uh it's I think that so any of
these fees
um again where I give you the agency
that collects that fee they would be
best to answer specifically what may
have occurred in that year and I know
many of them are coming before this
group in separate presentations I'm not
sure about secretary of state that one
example but
um I know department of safety insurance
labor like they're all they can explain
the nature of those exact fees that
particular swing is not not huge so it
could just be a timing aspect again
there's a budget and then there's
billing and collecting that occurs and
some sometimes things can be affected by
timing but that one in particular
doesn't seem like a huge swing not
compared to some of the swings we were
talking about with with indirect cost
recoveries but
um but yeah they they would I I couldn't
speak to exactly what what occurred in
fiscal 22 for that particular line item
but that is why if you do have follow-up
questions I know crochet can get you to
the contact people at these particular
agencies and that way they can tell you
specifically because again we we report
on it but we don't collect it thank you
you're welcome
say no other question I have one quick
question
um what is the minimum
number that it needs to be to track it
you said in other if it's you know it's
got to be above a certain threshold uh
it's that's a good question
um I don't think we've set a minimum
number but we've just again with these
categories that I've outlined here
traditionally have been ones that have
generated interest so you know if
there's anyone in those particular
agencies that are used to presenting
these items they we would continue to
track those over the years some of them
um a couple of them have dropped off you
know again if I would say if it gets if
it gets below 500 000 you know that's
probably a point at which we're probably
going to take them off sort of the
reported track list but they'll still be
in the untracked portion in there in the
accounting system so okay great thank
you
so that's that's all I have on
um General other again it's a small a
small category so I will be happy to
turn it over to Monica to speak with you
about the to the treasury items
okay any final questions
all right thank you
good afternoon Mr chairman a members of
the committee for the record uh say
Treasurer Monica mazzapelli and with me
this afternoon as the Director of
abandoned property uh Thomas mechanespi
so maybe before you start your your part
of the presentation we'll get to
representative fellow's second question
about abandoned property
yes and um I think
um
part of what I so my goal today is to
provide an overview of the abandoned
property uh program and I mean the quick
answer is that the 18 million is is our
estimate for our restricted Revenue it's
not the total property that we have for
for abandoned property but
um this is part of what I'll
plan to present to you all today uh to
talk about the providing overview of the
abandoned property program as part of
what um our restricted Revenue sources
if that's if that's okay uh
representative
so um I believe you have a presentation
and I was just asked to provide a very
uh brief overview of our department and
I I my intention is not to repeat what I
said last time we met so I'll be very
brief
um about our functions so
um and I'll I'll jump to um
uh page 13 and
um I mean I'm sorry page three and this
is just an overview of the functions of
the treasury so the treasury
um is um is is currently comprised of 23
positions and we see the treasury in two
main areas uh one is our cash
Investments the management of custodian
of our cash and Investments and our debt
management functions
um responsible for issuing bonds to
finance Capital products and the other
side of the treasury is what we call
Administration compliance or our
treasury operations so that's comprised
of the functions of again treasury
operations which which the treasury is
um we similar to the ministerial
Services we are a central Service Agency
you know we process and we see the final
payments um disbursements and cash
receipts yeah you know we have that
relationship with our banks to do that
and the other function that we have is
our section of what we are it's sort of
growing our College savings fighting and
plan are stable New Hampshire
um Savings Program and we also um we
have have the oversight of three
scholarship programs which we
collaborate with the college tuition
Savings Plan advisor commission for
those programs and the last piece there
is there abandoned property Division and
and that's the one I'll I'll focus on
this afternoon
so we do the treasury does not generate
Revenue we don't collect we don't
collect Revenue per se but we do
um end up generating two unrestricted
Revenue sources one SRS treatment
Revenue
um account and the other one is our
interest in surplus funds which that's
what I'll I'll talk about this afternoon
so moving on to page four
and this is just to do a quick dip dive
on then claim property program so we
pursuant to statute 41 40
471c we are responsible for
administering the abandoned property
program and and what it is is that we
are responsible for recovering
um and returning intangible property to
all rifle owners in air so this could be
citizens could be businesses could be
public entities municipalities
uh the the property that we receive uh
um is is
um could be unclaimed checks could be
cash could be bank accounts could be
insurance benefits customer refunds
stocks bonds and so we are we have all
those property to return to those
um those owners that that come forth to
claim in so this this Proverbs have
reported annually by institutional
holders and these holders could be banks
credit unions corporations utilities
insurance companies Etc
um they all again they're all
responsible to report to us and remit
all this property to the division of
abandoned property so in fiscal year 22
um
about 600
6500 institutional holders reported to
us and that was about
um over 27 million dollars in cash and
2.8 million uh in shares of stock or
mutual funds
um page five is just showing us the
10-year Trend and this is again what we
have collected uh over the last 10 years
and that is about 192.8 million and
that's an average of about 19.2 million
uh per year
so on page six
um
it just
talking about
um you know our responsibility to to
notify the rifle owners of the property
of Beholder that we hold
um and so each so we we do um generally
we do our reach and as part of that
Outreach and in advertising each October
we publish
um
a nano publication and the Union New
Hampshire union leader with all the new
names and all the new property that we
received in the prior reporting year
we also send um
we also mail postcard notifications to
um to those individuals and businesses
and we send it to the last known address
that we have so that occurs in the
months of August and September
so now we're able to
um
we called in our database we now folks
are able to do online searches and and
people can claim directly by going to
our website and that's how folks can
claim uh abandoned properties so right
now we are the website that we have is
New Hampshire dot find your
unclaimproperty.com but that's about to
change if it hasn't changed yet not yet
so it's going to be an easier name find
new hampshiremoney.gov so we're about to
change that name to to make it easier
for
um to claim to claim the funds but again
it's it's it's a it's a lot we have
implemented new technology and over the
last few years uh has you know in order
to facilitate and to to make it easier
for for the general public now we're
able anyone can search property online
and folks can claim directly so the
claim is is done so the claim and the
claiming of funds can can happen right
away we also implemented a new features
called Fast Track and now if the if the
claimant meets specific criteria the
system actually approves a claim and in
two weeks the claimer receives the check
so it's just it's right now we have
amounts those are amounts under a
hundred dollars but we're about to
increase the threshold we just wanted to
do some testing with that but it's going
really well and what that's doing is
really cleaning our database so folks
that were not willing to submit the
paperwork or so now it's easier to do it
and they get the check two weeks later
um so just uh so in first gear 22 the
division uh returned about 6.6 million
and that and
that was about um
789 claims
so page seven is showing uh again the
10-year Trend
um and it looks like um you know on
average we return about 6.5 million
um to the rifle owners uh each year
so that's really the goal of this
program to to collect all this unclaimed
property and the dormant property that
holders
um have and but if we're unable to
return this property
um during a period of three years the
law requires us to allows us to is cheat
that property to County treasures
or if his property from out of state
that is treats to the general fund and
so that's the unrestricted Revenue
amount that is um
that we report that we generate
so on page eight it shows we're showing
the calculation for fiscal year 22 and
and so all that does is it just shows
that's the property the line that says
net amount remitted that's for the
report year 18 so that was fiscal year
19. so that was property limited to us
and
um also the the claims against that
property so that's the net amount and
then we also
um this includes this proceeds from
Securities that we liquidate that was
about 4 million and 22 we are allowed to
subtract them in a certain expenses
and then um again this so the minus the
payments to the counties and physical 22
was 1.4 million and so and so the net
amount was uh 15.2 million that we
um
we generated for the general fund
so page page 9 is just showing you again
the 10-year Trend and this shows uh the
two components of our achievement is um
the the Char the bar the charts with the
bars just shows those are that's the
property from institutional holders and
then the bottom is showing um the
security liquidation proceeds and
obviously the the property that is
reported To Us by holder that's the cash
we we all know that amount is more
predictable the Pisa is more it's it's
just more unpredictable and difficult to
estimate is these are the Securities
that we hold and each year we sell those
Securities in order to achieve those
amounts to Regional funds so that's
um that's again an amount that is
unpredictable and it's based on the
value of the Securities at the time that
we we sell those Securities so
essentially it depends on the conditions
on the market
representative Ami
thank you
um
it's like FY 18 was a banner year for us
but
FY 18 reported
and cash claims paid
seemed normal
so is is this a year off the achievement
later than the
yeah with uh
if you when you see something like that
it means that we in that particular year
the um where the claims remain
relatively steady that's going to be
based upon that that's going to be based
upon the the uh two factors one we had
additional reports from
additional cash reports from holders
that particular year but if you also
look we had a good year selling the
stock the the Securities that we
liquidated that year were close to Six
Million Dollars
and you take a look at like fiscal year
2020 like the treasurer spoke to the
volatility we sell them at the same
period every year we don't want to
ever be saying like we're trying to
Leverage The Market or looking because
then you could never really pick the
perfect time to do it so we do at the
same time every year in fiscal year 2020
we sold it and it was you know during
the height of the pandemic the stock
market was down and you see that we you
know we had one of our worst here so
that's just that that becomes the you
know the very volatile part of putting
that estimate together
yes if I could follow up I think two
years ago we were asking if it would be
better if
things were sold every month instead of
all at once
I do recall that question I think um we
we did consider that if I recall I think
the difficult part is we we still have
to wait you know three years to to
um to know how much we're gonna cheat
and and we and um but the time at the
time that we start doing this
transactions we were just discussing it
starts in March to be able to start
um we notify our custodian it's time to
start selling security so it takes a few
months to do that
um you know those transactions so I
think it would be probably difficult
um to do it if we were to where to do it
more often
um so that's that's part of what you
know sort of um staying with what we do
is is not an exact science and we we do
our best system and I and I can in you
know on page 10 I was um was going to
talk about estimates but what we use to
estimate um
again this is sort of isn't a
predictable amount how much we're going
to return each year how much we're going
to collect this year but what we've been
doing for our estimates is we we base it
on a 10-year average and that's just our
history you know based on history and
that's just our best estimate what we
need to do and we were just um director
and I uh we were just discussing that we
need to do is compare how close we are
every time we estimate and we we don't
have that exercise for this time but
we're about we need to do that uh but
again that's you know using our history
is really the best methodology that we
found to be able to provide these
estimates
representative pleb I have to start with
basics in the term for a sheet that is
taking property from somebody who passed
who has no heirs
or is it broader than that
actually used as a misnomer in this
particular case a sheet is a true
Rasheed is the government taking money
that has no that will never be given
back so
in the in abandoned property in an
unclaimed property it is sometimes used
as called you know it's called in a
sheet but it's never truly in the sheet
because every state hasn't been a
property Division and they're all
because they're every it's all custodial
takings because the the individual or
The Heirs at law have the right to claim
that property anytime in the future so
there's never a truer sheet even though
we transfer the money to the general
fund it's always subject by law subject
to be withdrawn from the general fund so
we can pay that claim so it isn't that
truest sheet that you'd have there's
never anything that we take that's an
absolute Cruise sheet that there's no
one that could come forward I mean in
some limited instances that is the case
because there are people that die truly
with no ears
um and so that money once it does go
there is no chance that it would ever be
pulled out of the general fund
representative fellows
thank you
um I'm trying to understand
same title but they don't have the same
dollar amount am I supposed to
on page nine is it yes so so page nine
it just shows essentially the break I
guess make it easier on page 10 is just
the total amount so we as cheat to the
general fund page nine it shows that in
two parts
um the the the graph with the bars is
those are the properties reported to us
and essentially in cash from
institutional holders the um the bottom
section shows security so we call those
Securities so add them together for
three years because some some
individuals and some exactly some
businesses uh choose to re-register that
instead of receiving cash when they
claim they can re-register the stock
essentially and just we just transfer
that to them
and so when it's time to so when we
haven't been able to find uh the owners
of this property that's the time that we
do have to sell this and liquidate these
Securities in order to cheat in order to
send money to the general fund just like
follow-up so in in both of these the the
when you had to transfer the properties
to the county that that's in neither of
these that's already taken out it is
that's correct
that's correct this presentation doesn't
doesn't show the amount that we send to
the counties just what we send to the
general fund
thank you
and and so just to to conclude this this
part is just the again the the bottom um
portion of um page five is just showing
um the amounts that we're projecting for
fiscal year 23
um for first year 24 and 25 and again
these are these are based on our uh
10-year
um
history
I think you said page five but did you
mean page ten minutes and I'm sorry
about that did I um so page 10 okay I
was um looking at page time
so if there are no other questions about
unclaimed property I could move to
interest on surplus funds
okay
so interesting Surplus sponsors is
essentially the income that we generate
from from our investments
as you'll know the treacherous required
to invest
um any excess funds anything that we're
not contemplating for operating expenses
we we invest those funds
um so uh the interest income depends
obviously on the interest rate
environment and the average cash
balances that we have so
um as I mentioned when I was with you
during the last this last presentation
about three weeks ago our cash position
has significantly grown uh during the
last two years and that's uh primarily
due to the
um the arpa funding that we have
received so we know so right now what we
know is
um for the most part what's left is what
we call the state and local fiscal
recovery funds
um in that we we know it's going to be
with us for a few more years and so
looking at
um the dashboard that the Department
administrative Services prepares through
December 31st of 22 approximately 94
percent of the 994 million that the
state has received relative to this
particular
um
Grant
um only 94
94 has been allocated to agencies but
only 22 percent has been expanded so
we're trying to work with state agencies
to try to figure it out or to try to
learn the spend implants and that will
help us determine for how long we can
invest this fund so we're we're speaking
with larger agencies like Department of
administrative Services they have
received large amounts of this grants
Bureau of economic Affairs that's
another recipient of our large large
Grant from from this part of money and
so again we're working with state
agencies to determine how long we're
going to have those funds so we can
invest them
um so so from that from those funds that
we so we pull all the cash that this day
receives and from that uh we are allowed
to deduct
um or pay for our banking costs and an
investment fees from from that and from
those earnings
um so once we obviously calculate the
earnings we we need to this uh we need
to allocate um interest to those funds
who are entitled to receive interest so
we have
um the or make what we call our major or
major funds the par um dedication trust
fund receives an interest allocation for
example the lottery receives interest
allocation but also the smaller
dedicated funds are entitled to uh those
are those are entitled to receive an
interest allocation will receive an
interest allocation
um
so so with that um on page 12
we have I'm sorry we have a question uh
representative Ames sorry to interrupt
you in mid-sentence
so I'm interested in the state and local
fiscal recovery funds uh which you
mentioned and that indicated you're
working on that working with state
agencies to I guess figure out what's
going on and um
and there's also this uh apparent uh
part of this picture that involves
obligated funds and uh and expenditures
and um with respect to the obligating of
the slrf
slfr funds
um I I suppose that an obligation can be
disobligated if you will and then
re-obligated re-aligned as long as
you're working within the time frame of
the federal law so my question is
whether we can get a picture
of the whole of this thing
um and where we would go to get that
picture whether it's you or somewhere
else this is a lot of money we're
talking about close to a billion bucks
yes so I believe the LBA tracks
those locations I should have known
Chris Chris knows everything and what
the agency is so again about 94 has been
allocated but yes you are correct that
agencies can if they don't see uh if
something doesn't go the way they were
expecting they can go back and request a
reallocation or of those funds but you
again you're correct that the time end
of that needs to be prior to December
31st of 2022 and then the funds need to
be uh oh everything needs to be spent by
26.
um so but I believe that the lva is
tracking all of
those allocations you're welcome
representative
thank you on at your last point is to
get funds and to receive interest will
receive an allocation on
does that have to be written into the
dedicated fund language for every single
dedicated fund because I don't even
remember seeing it
well exactly so there are some dedicated
accounts that they do specifically State
shall receive an interest allocation or
one and those are the ones that truly
receive the allocation when the statute
allows and it says may we do not
consider those for for this exercise but
but yes we do have to review every
single dedicated account to know
which which fun is entitled to receive
an interest allocation so in
so again that that's what we do so so
there are some years as you can see on
page 12 which is my last page
um
it really is a revenue Source all over
the board it really is based on uh or
the interest rate environment so there
you know this is the 10-year Trend and
you can see essentially you can't really
count on this for to pay your bills but
um so we can see for example 2009 that
was a good year the rates that are
increasing during that time but then
again in 2020 the rates were cut and
that's you know and then the income the
interest income was reduced and during
those times when we don't receive uh
interest when we don't generate interest
uh you know we we use the lower you know
the earnings that we end up generating
are to be able to pay our banking costs
and investment fees unfortunately we
still have to pay those bills
um the good news is that with the rate
environment where we're we're in we we
are about to see some significant
changes so we are estimated and so
through fiscal year so by the end of
um
to December 31st of 22 we have recorded
about 17.2 million um and this is in a
cash basis
um that we we earned just by investing
you know the funds and we expect that at
least we'll probably see double that
amount so we're estimating that for
fiscal 23 we're probably going to see
about 35 million
is it is a conservative number it's
possible that we'll receive more than
that and then again in fiscal year 24
and 25 we're also using conservative
estimates but we expect about you know
in a neighborhood of 31 million and 25
another 24 million and again this is all
going to be based on so we're making
some some assumptions you know for
example for 20 24 25 whereas we're
making assumption that some of that
those thorough funds are going to be
spent so we're reducing those
um you know average cash balances but
we'll calculate
um you know we're calculating the
interest based on those assumptions
um but again based on the interest rates
and the expectation that the rates is
going to stay about where they are right
now we think that 20 24 25 will see some
interest income being generated in the
state can benefit will benefit from this
and with that that concludes my
presentation be happy to answer any
other questions or anything that I
didn't cover last time when we met
I I have a general question so the
interest rates you have here for example
for fiscal year 2023 four percent
um the latest CD rate I just saw was
about four percent are you is the state
putting money in CDs or what do you do
to get these interest rates yeah so we
we're our um
we are used in a variety the law allows
us to invest in in a variety of
types of security so we are we have
we're your lesson right now an
investment consultant that is helping us
to manage all this fund the state has
never really had well has never had this
much money or excess money and access
um
essentially
money in excess of our operating you
know what we need for operations so so
we're investing we have positions and
CDs we have uh positions we have U.S
treasuries we are investing in U.S
referral agencies
um
we have mutual funds we are are using
just our interest bearing accounts and
we are have a diversified right now
portfolio because we also need uh funds
to be liquid to meet our our our needs
and but we also know again if we're
going to have some funds for several
years we want to make sure that we take
advantage of the higher interest rates
and higher yields uh when we know we're
not going to spend you know certain pots
of money for one two three years so
we're looking at that the other piece
that has also helped to generate this
fund this earnings is a rainy day fund
so we invest a rainy day fund again with
the time same type of diversification
and all of the all of those earnings
from the rainy day fund go directly to
the general fund um per statue that
needs to be credited to to the general
fund great thank you any other questions
well representative spilsbury
thank you
um
I gather that the two billion dollars
currently on hand is unusually large am
I correctly understanding that the uh 78
unexpected arpa funds are part of that 2
billion they're in in that figure that
is correct so it's about that a billion
dollars that we have so that certainly
accounts for a major
degree to which they are greater than
normal
uh what is the minimum balance you
generally expect to need
just to meet the working capital
demands of State cash flow
that's a great question we just started
um evaluating that a little more but it
could be in the neighborhood of between
300 million and 600 million also that
also depends on you know when we have
times when we are
have good Revenue performance and as we
see you know more funds being collected
obviously that help us with the cushion
but it could be in the neighborhood uh
between 300 and 600 million and that's
what we want to make sure we have liquid
very liquid
so in other words in an interest in an
environment where interest rates are
increasing we get a a bit of a bonus in
terms of investment returns but you
would need a major amount of money just
in terms of managing liquidity that is
the three to six hundred minutes that is
correct but the good news is that we you
know right now because of the the
interest rates are higher so even
maintaining our funds with in in
interest bearing accounts or this you
know sweep accounts products that we use
we are we are seeing yields of you know
about four percent three percent and
that is perhaps it will keep moving
because of the um the activity of the
Federal Reserve so the federal received
the followers are keeps raising rates uh
we will see that even with those
accounts where we need to maintain our
funds very liquid
thank you
all right any other questions
thank you very much thank you
I'm sorry I missed some of that but I'll
make sure I read everything thoroughly
so we have a little 10 minute stretch
break before we begin go ahead we have
Chris here unless unless ajs is here and
we want to get going
okay good
yeah oh is it tonight yeah
well we still have a caucus so don't
leave
the characters
so well thank you I just had a couple of
things I just wanted to point out to the
committee so the treasurer was just
presenting to you the interest on page
12 of our document you'll see 23 is 35
million dollars potential 24 is 31 and
25 is for 24 million
if you look at what the Comptroller
provided in her document on page seven
row 29
which is the interest and surplus line
for Treasury
you'll note that those numbers are blank
so you when you're considering your
other Revenue you may want to include
these interest numbers that the
treasurer provided you
so for example
the projected revenue for 23 is 76
million dollars you may want to add
another 35 million to that to be closer
to what's projected should be projected
for the other category
if you want me to repeat that I can if I
was
too quick on you but it's page seven of
the comptroller's document
line 29
that is the line that has the interest
in Surplus from the treasury
the treasurer presented on page 12 of
her document what they project would be
general fund interest potential so again
you would want to add that to the those
two numbers yeah you want to add the
treasures numbers to the comptroller's
number to get a truer other estimate
could you add this to your spreadsheet
but break it out so that we can think
about it okay yep thank you and the
other there's two other things I just
wanted to touch base with when the
Comptroller was up she mentioned that at
the end of the budget process they take
all the information and come up with a
revenue plan
when they're doing that they consider
House Bill 2 changes and as I've
told this committee that if there's
changes to revenue throughout this
session we carry it on the Surplus
statement and the Comptroller will
consider that as they do the revenue
plan
going forward after the budget set has
been adopted and passed
if there's changes in the next session
that impact Revenue it's not going to
change your Revenue plan that that plan
stays the same the Comptroller may make
a note on the revenue Focus that there's
some impact of Revenue that's as a
result of a bill or some other action
that may have occurred so I just like to
say that because I get that question
throughout the process about you know
who's tracking these changes that we
support it's like it does get caught for
this cycle right so as you're building
the budget and your Revenue estimates
but in the next session if there's any
changes to that impact Revenue those
don't change your official Revenue plan
because the the unrestricted estimates
and the PLA and the budget have been
kind of adopted through the
um chapter law that's put it enacted
and then the last thing
representative Dames had a question
about the arpa funds so our office
tracks what's been allocated but we
can't track what's been expended because
we don't know
um gopher which is the governor's office
that has been tracking cares money as
well as the arpa money
is in charge of or responsible for
tracking the actual expenditures
associated with that because they need
to report back to the federal government
um we have made a request of them to
find out where we're at with the
expenses we haven't gotten an answer to
that question yet
um
but it does we do have a sheet that we
track we could provide to you that would
show you what's been allocated and where
it's been allocated
gopher also has a on their website a um
a graph that the colorful graph that
kind of shows you what's been allocated
and then but below that they'll show you
by category it's a water appropriated or
it's housing appropriation or its
Recreation appropriation and it'll tie
back to a fiscal committee item
um so again I can forward those links to
you just so you can look at that
representative Ames
that's helpful um
I guess I I'm wondering
um when you expect to receive an answer
to your request about spending and uh
when you started asking
um so we started earlier in the fall and
we haven't gotten anything yet I don't
know when to expect anything
um there was a report that
I think it was a September report we
asked after that to get another update
because there was additional uh
Appropriations made through fiscal
committee and because they had that same
type of question
um but we again we haven't received that
thank you
representative almi yep
does this mean that
potentially
in two years in in in
2026 on
we could find that like half the money
was actually expended
I suspect not because I believe Gophers
keeping a pretty good eye on that and
what they'll do and they have done
through fiscals they come in and
reallocate funds so if an agency came in
and had an idea to do something
and they were out we'll just make it up
but just say they were given five
million dollars to accomplish Project X
as they move forward in trying to do
Project X they realize that that we
don't need 5 million or we can't do it
they would notify gopher and say you let
us use 5 million we can't do the project
we thought we could do so you can have
that back and then they would reallocate
it but they're tracking that and that's
what makes part of the
um the expenditure question difficult
because the agencies it's not immediate
they may be allocated some funds to do
something it may take them several
months to determine if they can really
accomplish that with the appropriation
that's been provided and they may run
into other issues such as permitting or
Personnel or materials or whatever it
might be that keep them from from doing
that but again go for
I would suggest gopher will try to
expend as much of the money that's been
allocated to the state or make sure that
it gets spent they don't necessarily do
the direct spend but they would try to
make sure it could spend before it has
to go back to the federal government
representative fellows has a question
so oh oh dear
in terms of in terms of what we're just
been talking about I mean I will the
single audit get through Identify some
of this I know that's only through the
end of end of June but will that help
yes I was going to just mention to Chris
that and my office prepares the audit
report of all the federal financial
awards that have been spent based on the
year they were spent so you're correct
we are currently preparing the single
audit for fiscal year 22. it has a March
deadline so it's it's a nine month
process rather than the act for which is
a six-month process so it takes a while
it is fully audited by KPMG which is our
external audit firm so they're auditing
the arpa funds amongst all of the other
Federal programs Medicaid everything and
so that report while there's a lag it
it's based on the time spent so every
dollar that is spent is being reflected
in that annual single audit report for
the year it was spent so there will be
multiple years of this that you'll see
that spend take place but you can be
assured that it's being reported on by
Das and audited
each year so it won't give you the level
of detail that you're looking for
programmatically it will be this the
state fiscal recovery funds will be in
one line item but obviously there's a
multitude of detailed reports uh that
support that number
representative almonds
yes I'm still quite trying
I never have wrapped my head around how
I can find out enough about the budget
to suit myself but on does
uh
does that mean that the finance
committee at least or the fiscal
committee gets a annual report on how
much spending has been done and is left
to do
in
in those on different stimulus packages
we've been sent
through that report that Dana was just
talking about yes but on a more finite
detail you know if you're thinking
programmatically as an agency coming in
and reporting to fiscal or Finance
that's not happening
yeah so if I'm interested in housing in
particular I'm never going to know
for instance
so if you were interested in
um
I mean I I think that I've actually sat
in this room at times when a fiscal
committee has requested that a
particular agency present on their
programs so it can be requested the the
data is available
reporting representative Oliver you
think right yep uh thank you madam chair
and I don't know
where this is going to go but
individual programming is interesting
but not necessary for us to come up with
a resolution regarding our revenues I
don't correct me if I'm wrong somebody
correct me please I don't think it's
necessary it's interesting and it's very
useful
but getting
the amount of money that is
still available
unencumbered
is that figure
I'm getting confused and
unencumbered monies is for us to come up
with the budget we can spend this much
from federal money we can spend this
much from uh tax revenues and this much
from fee revenues
is are those figures available so with
arpa it's outside of the budget process
so those federal dollars are being
allocated
through fiscal committee and that's been
intentionally done that way
I don't believe
um
having not seen the governor's budget I
don't believe it's going to be included
in agencies budgets because it's funding
that is short-term they may have it for
through 26 but it's not something that's
going to be happening year after year so
I think the real reason that's been
discussed here today and how it impacts
this committee is when you start looking
at the interest Revenue potential on the
general fund because the treasurer is
able to invest those dollars that
haven't been committed yet and are going
to be spent within a certain time and
from that she's able to earn interest
for the State of New Hampshire
that is then deposited into the general
fund
okay so representative fellows
next
I just want to make sure that I don't
assume something that's not true
aren't some of the arpa funds directly
to a state agency for example the U.S
Department of Education to the State
Department of Education or are you
saying all of including that
goes through gopher
the state recovery dollars goes through
gopher there are direct Appropriations
to agencies for various programs
um but again I think it's
the
are you much much of that money won't be
in the budget but there are some
agencies that it's an existing program
where maybe it was enhanced through arpa
that may go through the budget but again
it's not the the state
um
slrf money so
so
um am I hearing that
when I hear about a certain program that
the recently there was an announcement
about the State Department of Education
using Federal
arpa related money for I think it was
online tutoring so do I not really know
if that was directly from the Department
of Education U.S Department of Education
to our ours or it could have been go for
money that came through gopher is that
the situation
that's correct I mean I would if there
was a source that you were wondering
about I would have to check and see what
you know where it came from was it a
direct from the U.S doe or was it from
some other agency
okay I just want to make sure I don't
miss anyone on this side of the room any
questions over here okay back to this
side representative Almy
on I think that it is of importance to
this committee to have an idea of
whether the massive stimulus funds that
came in are being spent
on now or are going to be spent three
years from now or never
because they are supposed to be
stimulating the economy and that is
where we get our revenue from
and I'll just put that out as a
discussion point
well again we can provide you the links
to the Gophers site where their reports
are we can provide you with the fiscal
committee report is
you may want to ask gopher to come sit
before the committee and explain you
know how they allocate and track what's
expended
if that seems appropriate but
I don't have that answer I don't think
the Comptroller has that answer at this
point and in terms of the spend rate
once an appropriation has been made or
an allocation has been made
because I think it's going to vary on
the programs and and what how the
agencies are set up to take in that fund
all right are we good on this right now
sure yeah oh representative Ames sorry I
just like to say that I I would for one
appreciate getting that those those
references that you you just mentioned
it would be very interesting man
I'll make sure the committee gets them
excellent but those extracurricular make
sure you do your base work first
that is spending we are Revenue we have
to focus on our bills and our task first
and then if we have free time we can
play with other things
okay clean up our sandbox
um
Nathan white are you here
there you are
come on up
welcome
thank you good afternoon members of the
committee my name is Nathan white I'm
the Chief Financial Officer for the
Department of Health and Human Services
and today I'm here joined by
Meredith Telus director of program
quality and integrity
and attorney Janelle Le Legion general
counsel love and manager of the New
Hampshire Department of Health and Human
Services Medicaid estate Recovery Unit
and we are here today to provide you an
overview of the Medicaid recoveries
um before you is a presentation that we
put together
um on page two uh all of the high level
projections for both state fiscal year
23 and what what we are predicting for
24 and 25 we have listed out there for
today's presentation
um Meredith and Janelle are here to go
through each one of these to talk a
little bit about child support talk a
little bit about Medicaid estate
recoveries and just to talk about some
of the variations that you may see from
year to year overall recoveries there
are some elements that we can control
when when predicting and projecting what
we anticipate to be the revenues coming
in from that but there are also a
variety of external factors for which we
cannot control so from one year to the
next depending upon the type of recovery
you may see some large swings just due
to
um a settlement or some type of audit or
other variable
um that that's external to the
Department's control so with that um we
can turn to page three and we can go
through each one of these and I will
hand it over to Meredith
good afternoon
so uh each of the
um
items that you see here is as uh Nathan
pointed out are related to various
Medicaid recoveries the first instance
is child support payments where a
non-custodial payment is ordered to pay
medical support related to the to the
child to reimburse Medicaid where
Medicaid is made a payment as you can
see it's a relatively low amount and we
expect it to remain relatively low
on the next page we have cost
settlements cost settlements are a
function of our payment methodology to
hospitals for outpatient
services and we have an arrangement
where we
um pay for critical access hospitals a
percentage of cost and for non-critical
Access hospitals another percentage of
cost so there's an interim payment made
but ultimately they have cost reports
that they submit to Medicare those are
audited and then once they're audited we
would do a settlement based on what the
cost is ultimately determined to be from
the when the interim payment was made a
few years prior so that can mean a
return of funds to the state or it can
mean that we have to give out money to
the hospital depending upon what their
actual costs were for that year and then
the difference in the settlement is the
amount ultimately that the state will
earn in recoveries
and that's what you see on page four uh
page five
um specifically these are supplemental
funds from diabetic supply manufacturing
companies this is an incredibly low
amount you'll see and I want to use this
as an opportunity to um to discuss kind
of a theme that you'll see which is that
a lot of these numbers are are low and
any of you that are familiar with what
the department had for recoveries in
Prior years like let's say over the last
10 years or so these are much lower than
those were and that's because we've
moved from being a fee for service
insurance company Medicaid where we pay
all of the services our fee for service
payments into a Managed Care Arrangement
so our managed care companies now
perform a lot of these functions for us
and we have a much much smaller
fee-for-service population and so we are
not earning the same recoveries because
we're doing it off a much much smaller
population
so that's um
diabetic supplies see the next one oh
other recoveries prior year yeah this is
just a line item that we have it it is
all of the same recovery types that you
see on the other Pages it simply has to
do with an instance where it's not
related to a service from this year it's
related to a prior year and so we put it
in its own category
page seven
the AG's office Fraud Unit these are
specifically instances where we are
looking at a particular provider and
suspect fraud it's referred to the
Attorney General's office they would
pursue that case and they can seek a
recovery
um and then that whatever the recovery
amount is there's a portion that is
returned to the federal government and a
portion that's kept by the state
yeah
yes representative ulery
I
have a threefold increase and
one year
so I my suspicion is that our our budget
for 24 and 25 are actually probably more
than Norm I'm not sure why we're so low
this year
um but normally these cases are very
much dependent upon what the AG's office
can kind of take on all at one time and
we do have instances where they can
either they'll settle or they'll win a
number of cases in a single year and it
bounces up and then for some reason uh
maybe a case is moving much more slowly
than they anticipated they have to do
more investigation and you have a lower
recovery
thank you
representative lippley
thank you madam chair are these numbers
per thousand or not per thousand are
they in the thousands
or these are these are total so it's
when it says 2024 agency budget it's 120
000 correct thank you yes so we're
dealing with a lot smaller numbers which
is why I mentioned earlier we we may or
may not want this particular agency to
come back because we're dealing with a
just a much smaller number than of
course we are with the dra right
so and something to keep in mind is
these are the general fund portions of
the Medicaid payments so depending if it
was a regular
um a traditional Medicaid where it's 50
50 goes back to the federal government
if it was a granite Advantage population
90 would be going back to the feds but
this is all that's left for the general
fund portion
uh page eight is program Integrity unit
so this is where we are identifying
instances of uh for us excuse me waste
or abuse not something that's turned
into fraud and goes to the AG's office
but just things that we would retain
within the agency because we identify
what we would refer to as waster abuse
in a provider and we do the recruitment
but it hasn't risen to the level of
fraud
and am I on page 10 9 thank you
oh member fraud yep so these are related
to instances of member fraud
um where there's been a court order for
us to recoup on a member who
fraudulently represented that they were
eligible for Medicaid
page 10 is related to
um what's called third party liability
so where a member has both Medicaid and
another form of insurance and the other
form of insurance should have paid for a
service and Medicaid paid we would then
go and recoup the other part of the
payment from that provider
and in this instance you'll see that
it's a little elevated in 23 and then it
goes down we did have an issue with our
Pharmacy billing that we managed to
catch up on so it's a little elevated in
this year we don't expect that to
continue
and on the next page
um Casualty Insurance so this is related
to instances of accident and Trauma
where there's subrogation of insurance
and um there was a particular case in
this year that earned the department an
additional amount of money
these generally both both what you see
on page 11 the TPL casualty and some of
the um other provider
um recoveries are just really case
specific and they are somewhat hard to
project we know we're not going to see a
million dollars out of any of them
necessarily but but it can bounce up and
down just depending upon this particular
case and when it might get settled
for estate recoveries yeah yep well you
guys deal in bigger numbers anyway so
and that is the um fraud waste and abuse
and TPL recoveries and I'll pass it to
Janella Legion to talk a little bit
about estate recoveries
oh yeah
where are we there representative thank
you madam chair you mentioned uh and
thank you for showing up and being here
today you mentioned that the state
Medicare system has switched to a
Managed Care model
um just two days ago Indiana I guess
yesterday Indiana well I guess it was
Friday Indiana announced a settlement
with their Managed Care Organization for
66 million dollars for over billing the
state
um in the past couple months we've seen
settlements with Texas
165 million Massachusetts 14 million
Washington State 33 million
um
I think Oregon and Iowa are well are
also working on settlements with their
case where their Managed Care
Organization promised to deliver savings
but in fact did just the opposite so
we're looking at
some of the fraud or fraud wasted abuse
I mean obviously we look at fraud waste
and abuse as it relates to the recipient
but also are you auditing fraud waste
for fraud waste and abuse of your
Managed Care Organization and is that a
transparent model that you're getting at
the state
we have thank you for the question it's
a great question we have a lot of
oversight mechanisms for our Managed
Care organizations I cannot speak to all
of them I can tell you that for for this
fraud wasted abuse and third-party
liability some of the mechanisms that we
use is we look at their
um we have reporting from them that we
compare to their claims so that we can
see the work that they're doing related
to those items and where we find them
less than satisfactory we can adjust the
rates that we pay those Managed Care
organizations to say this is what we
expect out of you and you're not hitting
that Mark so we're adjusting the rate
and we actually did that in our third
party liability area so that we we
basically said to them this is the level
of third-party recoveries we expect from
you and you can make it or not make it
it's not going to impact the state
because we've already adjusted our rate
for the amount we expect you to to
perform
follow up thank you
um have you ever contracted with an
independent auditor perhaps to take a
deep dive into because because you know
I mean these numbers that we're seeing
in these man because that's the trend in
the states is to go on to these
management they're staggering and I just
want to make sure that you know you're
right this is a small number that we're
dealing with today but I'm wondering if
there's more that the state is
overpaying for that maybe could be
uncovered
I would need to look at what kind of
each of those settlements were for the
state was part of a very large
settlement with the centene corporation
a couple of years ago and received 21
million dollars out of that so there
there are different settlements for
different purposes and I'm not sure what
each of those are for we have just
engaged with an auditor to do an audit
of the um
um managed care companies uh medical
loss ratio so the medical loss ratio is
an amount that we anticipate they're
spending on claims versus Administration
and profit and they report those to us
but we haven't done an actual audit of
it previously we've we've done sort of
what you call desk reviews we're now
going to start auditing those from the
mcos
thank you for the question
good afternoon my name is Janelle leiji
and I manage the Department's estate
Recovery Unit
this unit is federally oops there we go
federally mandated
we recover on behalf of the state the
federal government the counties and
sometimes the town depending on the age
of the assistance from which we're
recovering
at any given time we have about 2 000
open cases most of our recoveries happen
post death there are some that happen
during one's lifetime in the instances
where we have a lien secured by real
property
um
this uh what you see on page 12 is the
state's share of what we recover on
average over the last 16 years we
recover about six and a half million
dollars per year total
but as I indicated the state share for
just the medical assistance is about one
and a half million dollars we also
recover for financial assistance certain
types of financial assistance and that's
not part of the Medicaid Program so you
don't see that reflected here
if there's any other questions
I I with common to the million dollar
recovery for what it's worth we did just
process the check for one million
dollars and the state got half of that
so this year will be a big year
when we couldn't have predicted that
yeah we understand but thank you so much
representative Ames
sorry uh try again I want to dig down a
little bit into uh what this this
particular item reflects and um and I
write in thinking that at least a part
of it is
um
situations where the an individual who
legitimately was on Medicaid
but
um had a home
that uh the department gained a lean on
but continued to be served
for health care and the
costs eventually were recovered are
recovered by
by you through this estate recovery
system is that am I way off or
well yes and no
um
when someone has a home
the home may be subject to a lien only
in certain circumstances for Medicaid
they have to be over the age of 55. they
also have to be the permanent resident
of a nursing home that is they're not
expected to return home
and that none of the following people
live in the home or in the community
their spouse
a blind child a disabled child as that
term is defined by the Social Security
Act or a sibling with an equity interest
in the home that lived there for at
least two years prior to the other
person's entry into the nursing home
so in your example where you're where
your person had a home we would only
have a lien on it if all those that list
of criteria were satisfied which means
that person was open for Medicaid
long-term care services
and if they didn't have any of those
other people in the community they would
have also been required to sell the home
to help offset the cost of their care my
office may or may not have gotten to the
Opera gotten the opportunity to place a
lien yet we do always give people notice
and opportunity for a hearing before we
do that if we did have a lien and if if
it was if they had a hearing and it was
found to be appropriate all process is
satisfied we would recover from the sale
of the home up to the amount that we
were owed if there were enough in the
net proceeds I will tell you I've been
doing this for 15 years we have never
once forced the sale of a home or forced
anyone out of the home I just want to
add that
it's very important to us after someone
dies and they own a home in their estate
which is subject to a state recovery if
they want to stay in the home we work
out a repayment plan with them and
sometimes that means no monthly payments
at all it means deferring payment from
the value in the home out another
generation because that's the right
thing to do
and we still do well
representative ulrey
while it's not within your purview to
recover but there's also the five-year
setback in the
irrevocable trust aspect that applies to
some of this is that correct so the
five-year look back is something
different that's something that happens
when a person applies for certain types
of Medicaid Home and Community Based
care long-term care services are the two
that are most commonly
encountered by Medicaid applicants and
what happens when they apply for those
types of services
we look back at every transaction that
they made for the last five years
if it's found that they've transferred
an asset for less than fair market value
because sometimes
mom and dad want to give away the house
to their children so that their children
can have the house it might be that the
house has to be returned to them
because first and foremost
their assets have to be used to pay for
their care before the taxpayers pay for
their care and that's difficult water to
tread in as you may all well imagine we
do work with again with families to try
to explain it to explain the policy that
Medicaid is a payer of Last Resort and I
don't want to use the W word in a
negative way but it is a form of welfare
and so we have to try to balance that
and that is where Congress has chosen to
draw the Line in the Sand
but it it can be it can be touchy
if you had a question about trusts
because you mentioned irrevocable trust
as well
no the irrevocable trust don't apply in
this instance because that can be just
changed the drop of a hat but the
revocable TR or being strike that other
way around
irrevocable trust cannot be dropped
where the revocable one can be
if the asset were transferred into the
irrevocable trust within the five years
then it would count as an asset transfer
right f right provided that it is truly
irrevocable because as you mentioned
that can be changed I look at everything
Medicaid yes I look at every single one
of those trusts believe it or not
um it's not always the most exciting
work but it's very interesting I do you
must sleep well at night
wonderful thank you so much for coming
today
thank you for having us thank you
okay
fish and game is here come on up
thank you
my answer is that question
welcome good afternoon uh chairwoman Sam
Sanborn uh my name's Scott Mason I'm the
executive director at New Hampshire
fishing game
um
see how the my first time in front of
you folks was through
um
uh teams I guess this is a new
experience for me
uh I believe you all have our uh a
worksheet that we provided
um
our number one
uh income is from license license fees
uh broken down into licenses that would
be Inland Fisheries and and hunting
licenses salt water licenses salt water
license fees
um smaller item is the concrete agent
fee which is what we charge to folks
that come in and buy a license at our
windows in Concord
uh miscellaneous sales and income
um if you come to Wild New Hampshire
days you'll get an opportunity to buy a
sweatshirt or a hat
court fines and penalties
um if you get caught doing something
wrong and get a chance to go to court
those are the fees that fish and game
will try to receive
oh HRV license agent fees license agent
fees
interest on our savings deposits uh sale
a surplus property sale of surplus
vehicles Federal recovery income costs
game management transfers ohrv unfunded
road toll and Marine unfunded road toll
you'll note that during covert we did
see a sharp increase in sales on
licenses that has started to decline as
we move away from that one of the things
is when things all shut down and kids
were home from school and parents were
home and their children they were
looking for
some fun things to do that didn't
necessarily get you into a big crowd and
fishing and I and hunting in those types
of activities uh soared through the roof
for a few years unfortunately for our
license sales things are coming back to
normal and kids are back in school
participating in school programs and
parents are rushing around trying to get
them from one thing to the other and and
and they're no we're not selling the
licenses we did during that time frame
foreign
thank you madam chair um I guess the
thing that jumped right out at me was
the salt water licenses being zero why
is that
hi I'm Kathy Labonte and I'm the chief
of the fine
um business division so I oversee all
finances for the Department I put this
little spreadsheet together and what it
is actually is kind of like a snapshot
view of all of our unrestricted revenues
from fiscal year 13 through 22 is actual
23 is budgeted with the exception of the
unrefunded road toll the two at the
bottom those are actuals and to answer
your questions sir saltwater licenses
were a separate receipt account all the
way through fiscal year 15 where they
were accounted for separately when the
salt water license was enacted
and then it became apparent that it
really wasn't worth it to keep that
saltwater license separate from our
other license revenues so we just put it
together with our other licenses
so it's part of the overall license
Revenue
lots of questions uh representative
yeah just to elaborate on the saltwater
license I seem to remember that we put
that in effect in order to forestall a
higher uh federal license that was being
put on if the state didn't have a
license then we were gonna
it was going to cost the the the striper
fishermen more money to get stripers
than if he bought us a ticket from us
that is true it was going to be 15 at
the Federal level or ten dollars at the
state level
and there's not that many we don't have
good starters you got to go down to the
cape
representative all me I'm sorry I missed
your hand earlier
thank you I just can't distinguish my
name anymore
on
I
how big is your total budget this is
just a very small piece of it isn't it
yes
if you take arfa out of the picture it's
about I'm sorry if you take arpa out of
the picture it's about 32 million
okay representative fellows did I see
your hand up before
okay
so my question was about the fourth line
down the miscellaneous sales in income
so I'm assuming that includes
like I every year I make a donation to
the non-game fund so is that in that
line or no the non-game program is a 100
percent dedicated program there are no
unrestricted fishing game funds within
that program so your donation goes
directly to fund that okay it's not on
here that's correct the biggest deposit
into the miscellaneous sales and income
of about three hundred thousand dollars
is actually an internal administrative
charge that we charge to our dedicated
accounts to pay for the overhead of
people such as myself and people in the
business office and people within the
director's office who work on those
dedicated programs
representative shamberg
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking this question it has to do with
the unfunded road toll on both the ohrv
and the Marine
is that a percentage of of just a quick
explanation it's not a percentage it's
actually a formula based on the amount
of Regis for ohrv it's based on the
amount of registrations sold
and it's the same for boats for the
amount of boat registration sold and
those funds come to us from the
Department of Safety they do all of the
the mathematical work
thank you
representative ulery again
yeah I'm just to elaborate on
representative Schaumburg
and some people don't no
ohrv and Marine do not are not
responsible for paying the road toll
which is dedicated fee
for Highway Maintenance
so if you
go and get gasoline for your jet ski or
for your uh four-wheeler you don't have
to pay the fee you take your receipt
send it in to you and you reimburse them
the the tax but if they don't do that
then this money is comes in but it's not
real money it's an accounting
Revenue am I correct you are correct
thank you
are there any up yep representative
Rushford yes thank you madam chair so
Federal recoveries what is that is this
is the Fed feds give you fund you Monday
through grants is that is that what that
is
[Music]
indirect charge on all of our federal
grants and we have 50 plus different
federal grants
and we do a formula-based methodology
every year on an annual basis and it
runs between 18 and 19 percent and again
that is a charge to be able to pay for
the overhead of people in the business
office and the director's office that do
not directly charge federal grants
that's what those funds are so similar
to that miscellaneous sales and income
where you said 300 of that was to cover
you charge yourself we charge our own
dedicated accounts yes sir all right
thank you you're welcome
representative orrs
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question the safe hiking pass
is that included in these numbers it is
not that's a dedicated revenue and that
goes directly into the search and rescue
account
thank you
all right go ahead may we ask a further
questions uh regarding the uh safe
hiking and the the rescue aspect of Fish
and Game which uh I understand takes up
a massive portion of your budget
that's restricted funds but it is
restricted funds yeah so that's not in
our peer review really oh would you want
to yeah you guys just are curious about
everything I love it
I I specifically told the director there
would be no other questions other than
unrestringent questions guess what
however the uh I would like to know
whether or not that safe hiking passes
is making us a significant impact or
whether and because that came before
this committee when it went into effect
it absolutely is
and it is making an impact it is helping
to offset some of the costs it is it's
covering a lot of the variable expenses
associated with search and rescue but
it's not generating enough income yet to
cover
um the hourly wage and benefits of the
COS that are involved in it but it does
cover like any overtime
equipment purchases that kind of stuff
uh thank you madam chair for me one
further question follow-up if you
believe that it's not generating
sufficient income could your office
examine that to determine whether or not
a fee increase may be appropriate and
perhaps reach out to uh this committee
as to uh modifications that may be
necessary before the filing period for
future legislation
um actually last year the legislature
gave us the power to go through
rulemaking to set the fee on hike safe
cards like on our licenses
um right now we are trying to we're
working with some outside groups like
U.S forest Service
um spin-off and some of the other groups
to look at ways that we might be able to
increase sales at the existing price
um you know we're just scratching the
market right now we know we're not
selling to everybody that's going hiking
and if we can try to change that and
increase those sales that would serve
the same purpose
it is voluntary yeah Madam chair yeah it
is voluntary and I know several other
states that have a a similar uh
environment that uh have been taking a
good long look at that as a method so we
actually have had
um phone calls from as far away as Spain
from
other folks that are looking at trying
to to come up with the same similar
program to this
representative fellows right thank you
okay
I'm just wondering if you did something
like when they bought the hiking card
that you gave them something like one of
those mylar blankets at the same time
that might be an incentive but that's
not my question my question is what what
is why is it so long high on line four
the miscellaneous for FY 20.
um we sold our Brentwood Game Farm
that is when we sold Brentwood and the
revenue was deposited into our
miscellaneous account
in those revenues subsequently were used
and this was part of that sale they were
subsequently used as matching funds for
a one million dollar branch
for our Reserve program for the Glencove
Wildlife Management Area
you're welcome
representative janaian
thank you madam chair so if that was
used for one time does that mean
this is going away after this
miscellaneous um item then we'll drop so
it was a capital sale it was a real
estate sale it was a real estate sale
yeah
oh okay
representative all me a different
question on the same thing if this is
supposed to be unrestricted Revenue
going to the general fund
how were you able to use it as a
one-time match
we designated the funds sorry we
designated
to be able to use unrestricted fishing
game funds to match those Grant funds
as all grants the funds are not used
until the expenses incurred so the funds
actually just sit in the unrestricted
Fish and Game fund until the expenses
incurred and then we use the funds so
really they're just sitting in a pot
until
we make the expect we incur the expense
so
is this
this is an unrestricted fund within
fishing game
that we're looking at or this is these
are all unrestricted within fish the
fish and games okay
okay so no general fund involved in this
no not at all there are no General funds
here yeah
so then
under all of this
is the 50 plus or whatever no that's
federal grants but uh
however many sub funds you've dedicated
funds you've got now
they're only 15. we have about 15
dedicated funds so we've Consolidated
just about everything it used to be
about 50.
you had turkeys and you had ducks and
representative Malloy has a question or
comment thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question
would you believe that I live in
Greenland and we do appreciate your uh
work on Glencove
thank you
representative Morris thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question do you folks keep statistics
on recovery and rescue from various
States in other words if you rescued or
recovered 100 bodies
honey do you have a Breakout by state
and if so should we be charging more for
Massachusetts and New Jersey
probably wouldn't get away with it for
very long
um
so when we do a rescue if
the person first of all obviously we
want to make sure to encourage people to
pick you know to call for help when they
when they need help you want that call
to take place we never want to have
somebody sit there and and worry about
paying for the rescue and therefore not
making the call and therefore having you
know turning an incident into a tragedy
um but we do have the authority
um in certain cases uh to collect the
costs of a rescue
um and that goes through the Attorney
General's office they approve each and
every one of these that we bill out and
then we build those out and we do
collect money regardless of the state of
residency it runs off the top of my head
I would think it's running about 50 50
New Hampshire residents and and out of
state folks as far as that goes we also
have the authority to charge people
um and I apologize that Reckless conduct
negligence if you've done something
that is excuse me
called the Darwin fee I'm sorry
so if you've done something that is now
putting the rescuer's life at risk
um we have the the ability to to charge
somebody with criminal penalty and this
year was the first year we did that
thank you very much
okay thank you very much for your
presentation we really appreciate it
Chris do you want to come join us for a
few minutes
ah
Chris remind me how many more agencies
have we not had an initial presentation
from
so you've had presentations from The
Usual Suspects that they come to Ways
and Means everybody's been through at
least once okay good um
tentatively penciled in Wednesday
February 22nd as a day to do more
and right now I have dra
and the governor's budget director
penciled in but I do know that February
22nd is potentially a session day
so I've made a dra aware I haven't
contacted the governor's budget director
yet but what I suggested to the
commissioner of dra is that if for some
reason the 22nd doesn't work we'll try
to spinner into the 27th
yes
um
because obviously the 27th 28th March
1st that's when we really want to start
getting our projections done because
finances bugging me daily
to get those and of course our hands are
slightly tight until we hear the
governor's budget which is next
Tuesday right yeah next Tuesday so we're
a little bit tired until then but we
want to make sure that we can get it
done soon thereafter so
so as of this morning we have dra coming
back on Monday the 13th they'll be here
from 10 to noonish
so that you can finish the they can
finish their presentation to you but as
well if there's questions that you had
left over from today you can re-ask
those so if you know you're thinking
about the material that they provided
and reading it over the weekend you're
like oh geez I a little confused on this
bet and how it might re you know
interplay with BPT you could re-ask that
question to try to sort that out before
we get into
um
dra sitting with you and doing the
estimate ranges because I think as you
heard from the commissioner today
they're gonna
try to account for some aspects of the
changes in law but they're going to try
to show it separately so it's going to
be a little bit different I think for
members that are veterans to Ways and
Means for new people it's not going to
be as anything different but for those
that have been here before it may look a
little bit different in some of the way
they show their projections which may
generate additional questions
just as a reminder Chris will be
populating a big spreadsheet with what
the agency
projections are so what you have heard
up to this point from the agencies
um so like for instance today with the
other Revenue I'll be putting that into
this Excel spreadsheet that will show
you what the other Revenue projections
are but from the agency's point of view
right so that you'll have everything in
front of you
um you also will have what the governor
is recommending
you'll have what the plan was for 23.
and you'll have what the plan was for 22
and what the actual Revenue was for 22.
so you'll have a little bit of History
right in front of you as you look at the
um the information that's coming at you
dra until I see what they're providing
I'll figure out how we might have to
show that to you if it's going to have
multiple levels that may not fit in the
traditional spreadsheet that we've used
um
the only agency that not the only agency
excuse me the one agency you do need to
have come back as a lottery when they
presented before you they didn't provide
you with their 23 24 25 estimates
um
I could ask Charlie uh director McIntyre
if maybe he wants if the committee is up
for it poke his head in on Monday
you know in the uh you know come in at
noon at the end of Lindsay's
presentation and and just give you a
quick what he thinks is 22 3 24 25 would
be or I can put it off to the following
yeah let me run it by folks here on that
but at a minimum could he email them to
us oh sir that would be great as soon as
possible so we can start looking at them
and then if we feel like we have
questions we can see when makes sense
from members
okay
yeah representative fellows so when we
start working on this on the estimates
how do we approach it do we like start
with the ones that are those the smaller
ones and work our way up or how does
that go
uh let me ask Chris that
it's been a while since I saw that
spreadsheet how do you how do you have
that organized
well I have it it's it's organized on
how it's presented okay in the in the
budget I guess for me personally taxes
and then it'll go through to recoveries
is the last thing I think
the committee has approached it in
different ways over the years sometimes
the committee will try to get those
revenues that are easy or not
contentious out of the way
that you're going to say swept is going
to be 363 million
statutes going to guide that so you say
okay we can agree to that
just as an example you may say that the
other Revenue you know we're going to
trust with the treasurer and the
Comptroller has put before us and we're
comfortable with that number we're
comfortable with Securities we're not so
comfortable with liquor so we want to
hold that for a minute because we want
to consider some things with liquor so
it would really be up to you know the
committee and the chairs to or the chair
to decide how you want to kind of tackle
I guess that was my thought while we're
talking about this is we'll start with
some easy stuff first that you know like
some of the numbers we looked at were
fairly small
there's not much wiggle room there we'll
probably start with some of the easier
stuff first
um and then start having conversations
about maybe the more controversial I
don't know liquor maybe one
um and see where we are and look at the
range of possibilities there and then we
might have to caucus
and see where each side is on and then
come back and see what we can you know
if we're gonna have two different
numbers or we're gonna have one average
or how we want to handle that but some
might take several discussions we want
to start and then come back to it
some will be easy and you know obviously
all the dra numbers are going to be a
lot more thoughtful so we might need to
come back the next day to do it again
yes
so I'm I'm thinking that some of them
can be impacted by things like
um inflation and job reports and so I'm
thinking though you know you can't push
them out too far but we might be able to
get like a little bit more information
on some of those factors I'm just mostly
thinking about business Enterprise and
business profits
yeah in fact we had an economist come to
our economic briefing back
early January I guess it was and we he
had only had data through a certain
point and we'd asked for a an upgrade on
that do you remember who that was
that Brian yeah
yeah maybe him and then there was
someone else from an outside bank or
something
um
uh I'll have to go look at my notes um
but yeah it would be great if we could
go back to them and and see if they
could have an update
and they could at least just email it to
us yeah representative ulery or
Southworth I can't see a hand thank you
he's flagging for me
you know I was just going to add the
last few times have gone really smoothly
and um you know I'm just not sure we
want to make any major changes in the
process what he's done before he's had a
spreadsheet it actually started with
business taxes it had the highest and
lows recommended by dra we all got that
ahead
um the caucus has got to talk and think
ahead and then when we sat down we were
ready and we just went through and
sometimes it was near lunch we'd say
can't we polish off an easy one but what
he did with us the last several times
was very systematic because maybe you
know there needs to be a little more
communication but I just want to put
that out there excellent yes uh and that
was my experience several years ago as
well that lbao really helps us through
this so they'll hold our hands
throughout the process
representative only did you have
something
yeah yeah one thing that I hope Chris
can follow through with the
um I think it was yeah Dana gave us Dana
Cole gave us the uh
other revenues without the Surplus
interest in it
and on the treasury gave us Surplus
interest right but
um just to make sure that on Mr Arling
house doesn't disagree with putting that
number in there so I I don't know when
they were here if you saw me talked
about the controller and the treasurer I
would confirm that they were okay with
taking that interest number and adding
it to the other and that's why I had
brought it forward to you guys just to
make you aware that they were not
included the interest was not included
in the other and that you may take that
what the treasurer is recommending or
you may adjust that to be something
slightly different depending on the the
desire of the committee
um and if I could just back up to
representative Southworth and just kind
of piggyback onto his comment
um I will provide the committee you know
as we get a little bit closer with the
spreadsheet I'll give it to you in a PDF
and I'll give it to you in Excel I'll
email it to everybody
um
the Excel would be meant to
um work on on your electronic device and
make your adjustments don't try to print
that because you may run into some
issues the PDF would be meant if you
wanted to print something but I'll also
have hard copies anytime we get together
so I would provide you the hard copies
but if there was a caucus occurring you
may want to print a copy for yourself so
you can write it up you know ideas and
suggestions or that so I just want to
let you know but if at any point you're
feeling like you're missing something or
you need something please reach out to
me you know you have my contact
information shoot me an email and say I
don't have the worksheet or I don't have
this presentation or I need information
X let me know and I can get that for you
so that you have everything you need as
you're working on your Revenue estimates
and your ideas and thoughts
representative Wars
thank you madam chair and thanks for
taking my question would the Excel work
with the Chromebook version I forget
what it's called the spreadsheet in
Chrome Chromebook do you know I assume
it would I don't know I honestly don't
okay we can test it and make sure it
does thank you so
you're asking a non-it guy
representative all me
what about the idea of on just mostly
working this out in caucuses and coming
back because I do think that we learn
from each other and each of us has a
different take on the economy of the
state and what it might be doing to the
revenues and half of us don't get to
hear what the other half are discussing
when we do it that way
so it does mean more time together but
I think it produces a better product
speaking as someone who had the upper
end of the the revenues estimates last
term and
your side had the lower end and we just
took the median or mean or something of
them
and the revenues came in above what all
of us said so
I'm very open-minded I'm here just to
help administer the process uh you know
your wishes are my command yes
representative fellows um yes so one of
the statistics that came out recently in
the news had to do with
um job growth like more people being
hired and also about the ratio of
uh unfilled position in in people who
were looking for work and so I'm really
interested in hearing a little more
about that because I think that that
would have a big impact on business
Enterprise taxes and I don't want to
slow down the process but if we could
have that Economist come and talk to him
and even if we only say like you have to
keep it to 10 minutes or so 15 minutes
something like that just I really would
like to have that input
Chris is that something you could help
us with
which Economist represent fellows do you
mean uh Brian I think it would be easier
to get Brian here
than it would be the person from The
Reserve Bank yeah
Reserve Bank person I might see if
Jennifer will email that person and if
there's an updated report like a simple
summary report we could get just to get
an update that would be helpful but he
doesn't have to drive all the way back
yes
exactly yeah okay if you could reach out
to Brian Gottlieb yeah and I try to
schedule him for either the 27th or 28th
depending on what he's available for
yeah just to yeah like you said just
brief update because we don't get the
full presentation but now we just want
to get it updated yeah that would be
great
uh we have settled on dear here dra here
to finish what they started today this
coming Monday so next Monday February
13th from 10 to noon
which gives you guys enough time to do
what you need to do in the afternoon
and then uh
it's Monday then on Tuesday we have a
session
so we're busy with that
then what the governor's budget which
will help us because we can waiting to
see what we got going on there and then
the following week uh we'll get going
again as best as we can so there's some
deadlines coming up for the freshmen so
you know that we have to get some
committee work done
it at a house session and so we're up
against a deadline that Wednesday the
22nd and Thursday the 23rd so you might
have two back-to-back session days so we
just don't know yet
so that's a little wild card so I I
can't schedule too far out there we
definitely know
the last week of February the Monday
February 27th Tuesday 28th March 1st
we're getting down in business
right
yeah
in the 15th that's right I forgot about
that which is next Wednesday
I think we should do our remaining Bill
hearings
and I'm hoping we can also exec some
bills that day the bills that we've
already heard
so I'll list that they'll list them all
and we'll see if we can get that done
while we're here
okay
no I think there's four plus a bill that
was passed through e-dna and then we're
the second committee so there may be a
total of five bills
some may not need a lot of time and so
we'll see if we have time to do an exact
session if we will if we're able to take
up some pills and deal with them
basically we'll try to
representative Mommy
that fist bill olpc
that is going to take time is it okay so
we may or may not be able to do that I
probably want to do a work session on it
later so okay all right so maybe that
one might need a little bit more time so
at a minimum you know there's like four
bills that we haven't heard anything
about yet which we gotta get scheduled
and it's assortment of different topics
so we'll get those done I'll put the
exact session on the calendar in case we
can do it because we gotta we have to
notice an executive session even if we
decide not to do it and just recess it
but at least we have to notice it in
case maybe there's some things that we
we can deal with
okay
okay great
thank goodness for lbao and Chris Shea
wait till we get through the process
we're totally trusting you
so uh Republicans will be caucusing now
we're going to go upstairs to the one of
the 300 rooms I don't know what number
it is but we'll figure that out and
we'll just uh chat about the schedule
okay